the great tim kennedy
scars and stripes what are you looking
at his wife yeah i mean you got a nice i
mean because you you're not a big fancy
guy but that rolex so all of my watches
no no no so this book the sub no no this
is all this is like sf era stuff the
submariner and the omega speedmaster
have a long heritage with pilots and and
special forces operators
so it's kind of like a right to patch
passage thing to it's not like this
bougie thing
you can't wear that in in countries no i
wear like my omega speedmaster in
country what do you wear
mega cuts to me with one of those i
don't wear a watch yeah it's like what
they went to the moon on yeah
but but you like that you could actually
like the submarine you can you can yeah
that's what it's meant for yeah like my
you know this is a the the italian navy
back in the yeah it's awesome 30s i
didn't mean to like lean over your
business
but
i don't beautiful
let me let me start this with saying if
you were in the zombie apocalypse
and you have three weapons oh god what
are they okay
um wow yeah it's great great segue good
start i'm starting to start so
if there was a zombie apocalypse would
you leave your invisalign in well we
already went through that and my teeth
gave it to him ten more days bubba okay
ten more [ __ ] days
i got some straight teeth can't really
see it
how do you do your teeth fair pretty
well in fighting yeah my teeth work
after fighting they're really sensitive
he grinds wait back to this yeah please
i want a long range a long range you
know like a scar 20s and chambered in
like a 6'5 creedmoor so it can reach out
to like maybe mile mile and a half
pretty effortlessly just like a sniper
thing sniper round
um sniper round with a sniper weapon
system but it's semi-automatic so i
could put a lot of rounds on target you
know of course so are we talking fast
zombies or slow zombies we're talking
probably are we are they slow yeah
they're not the ones from world war z
that'd be a big problem all right
they're slow these are the things i
think about for me to go to sleep at
night
but my thing if it's a zombie like say
tim turner's a zombie he's pretty fast
and agile like just because you're a
zombie i mean you're getting slower
there's a lot in the comments i would be
bored i would be bored with the slow
zombie so just for my my friends okay so
so so world war z brad pitt zombie yeah
i want those zombies i want those no no
you don't want them but i'm going to
give you this hold on
they're as fast as a regular human being
okay yeah and that's that's significant
and they're zombies and they and they're
attracted to sound and they will eat you
they're attracted to sound all right so
go you got the long long long long rifle
20s 6.5 creedmoor that is for sure i'd
have a short barrel rifle like a 10 10
inch 14 stock
like an m16 or an m4 yeah like but like
a short short note a short ar
a short a m4 suppressed yeah
and um and then uh a good pistol like
the fnls edge or
um
any striker fire combat pistol four to
five inch barrel you know high magazine
capacity all the bells and whistles the
same three guns you would have with you
if you if you can pick when you're like
in afghanistan or the cartoon same guns
yeah same guns no machete
no
so standoff standoff is the ability to
engage somebody without them being able
to engage you anderson silva he had
standoff of most people he could punch
or kick them outside of the range in
which they could punch or kick him like
when the chinese were like hey i can
take some gunpowder stick in the back of
this thing put an explosive projectile
in the front of it standoff arrow
standoff the greek with spear standoff
so you always want that so like if you
have a machete and i'm like
nice talk you know it's like oh you have
a shotgun cool i have an ar cool you
have an ar i have a sniper rifle like i
just
distanced but there are times when
you're close and personal like your book
what i was amazed at how many times
you're you're so close you can grab the
barrel which is so insane that was not
ideal
yeah i mean that's that's like shooting
a single leg on harder gracie and he
kicks the leg over and takes my back
that was not part of that
yeah but you figured your way out yeah i
did but i was like just watch that fight
yeah you've never seen it no
holy [ __ ] like the best rapper the
grappler ever in his best position i
didn't know he's that good
i'm naive no hodger's really good oh
[ __ ] yeah someone would say the best
yeah yeah really oh yeah of the gracie
bad bad plan so again like i don't want
to be that close bad plan bad execution
i wish i could like play the tape back
again and redo but there's no mulligan
that's a golf thing right yes there are
things i learned there are things i
learned in this book first of all i
texted you when i read it i texted him
it i've you know i it's not a secret i
read a lot it's it's such a well-read
book and frankly i was very surprised
and very relieved because you read books
a lot of times if it's a friend of yours
book and usually it's not that good is
that a compliment
how do you take that because i don't
look at you i don't pleasantly surprised
that look at the [ __ ]
as author authors a whole different
skill set but never look at what he's
doing i'll leave it to tim kennedy
mm-hmm he's a thinker
not only do i have the great chest hair
but i have two things going for you one
is your thinker two is you are your
calves you're incredibly honest and
you're very self-deprecating so the
state you said you're gonna go dark when
the beginning of the book yeah and
you're you're gonna tell about tell us
about everything oh my god i was saying
like his failures like all the things
that went so wrong right like
my mom my mom that's a good point for
her church group that's just got this
book and i was like
can we do not that they get it you don't
they get it you know little women maybe
you can never look bad when you're that
honest you can never look bad when
you're that honest all your skeletons
yeah yeah i don't know online's pretty
sad like arnold schwarzenegger when
they're like yeah he like was hooking up
with his maid
and uh and then made this child outside
of wedlock you know he cheated on a
kennedy you know i killed his book sales
people didn't buy his book do you know
that yeah that's my point yeah it's like
you can be too honest brian there's
times where you're like
you know
this book is next to me i don't want to
look at it because you know but to
arnold's point again that's basically
how gracie having your back you figured
it out because now that kid got his
genetics he's the only one who got his
genetics looks just like him jack wait
let's go to let's let's go to what we
were talking about speaking of kids and
genetics
because we were talking about a positive
guy yeah we were talking about you bro
that's a good point we were talking
about how operators like you guys you
tip of the spear guys almost always to a
like almost always to a man have girls
you when you have children yeah it's
always girls when they have children
always girls do you know that high
testosterone too like most uh ufc
fighters don't have girls really joe
rogan
sweats testicles brian stan has like
nine girls jon jones has like 17 girls
god it's all girls
and i have two boys
[ __ ]
listen we're not saying you're not tip
of the spear nor are we saying you're
not like maybe in comedy i mean comedy
you know champion level physique
you're gonna make a lot of videos but
yeah i feel like i have a lot of
testosterone i have two boys yeah first
special forces command uh they they have
like did research trying to figure out
you suck trying to figure out what is
going on if you walk into a special
forces oda and you and you take all 12
dudes and you say all right
carlos how many kids you have he's like
four girls ben how many kids do you have
three girls like you just go right down
the row if you find a boy in the mix
he is like he's held up as like this
adonis
up in the air i wonder if that's
nature's way of saying there's too much
testosterone here we gotta we gotta
balance [ __ ] out
yeah surround it all the time you know
pheromones are pumping testosterone i
don't know what it is it is strange it's
weird they have a bunch of but you have
boys
no i mean i i had to get weird to get a
boy
yeah you were saying you have a
technique would you i don't i don't have
i don't own the technique i did research
to find out that there are there's a
there was a plethora of techniques like
positions yeah position so male swimmers
swim faster but don't last as long so
like an ovulation if you have
if if you if you come
early in our ovulation like there's more
time for the female swimmers to make it
up there but if you have
to make it to egg to fertilize but if
you do at the end of ovulation it's just
gonna be the fast boys and then it's
over and if you didn't get a a boy cool
you could try next time um positions
like trying to deposit deeper and then
um it is so gender is 100 determined by
the male 1 100
and body fat body temperature uh like
athleticism these are all things that
skew towards
female offspring whoa yeah so but so if
you you just finished working out for
example bad time bad time bad time you
want you want to be on bed rest yeah a
man like you has got to be on bed rest
while reading
watching hallmark i took a month off
i flew to germany i hung out in like
with a bunch of german and nordic
norwegian
like dudes that looked like this dude
like all of them look like that guy but
why would you do that just because it
lowers your testosterone
cold cold weather no hot showers no
briefs no exercise you were dead serious
about that you did all this [ __ ]
for the boy no exercise no exercise holy
[ __ ] yeah i mean i did like some dancing
uh yeah like beer gardens in germany you
know yeah like a good morning you know
and like yeah i'm not gonna say no i
cheated yoga in the morning they got
like those little uh the outfits that
the the girls wear yeah yeah did you go
did you change your diet
oh yeah you did yeah so what's your
fault for the boys charcuterie boards
wine
i mean how probably how you live
how you live is what i did to try to get
your brand accounts yeah and then like
it's soft
to try to try to get a boy and then like
afterwards i'm holding my naked wife by
the ankles like shaking her you're like
come on get in there see you
holy [ __ ] i'm not joking and then it
worked and we'll get a boy got me a boy
it's just the one jack three girls and a
boy he's the hope he's the oh how old is
he now yeah he's seven does he have your
athletes he's a savage he is yeah how
could you not be though he looks
the opening scene in the last mohicans
we're talking about lacrosse yeah um he
plays a cross he's got striations on his
shoulders he's got this v on his back
already already he has long hair that
goes down in the middle of his back and
he takes off his lacrosse helmet and
it's like matted and tangled from being
all sweaty and uh he just looks like a
savage that's straight out of the last
time he cans and he plays hockey he
writes motivation he wants to say it out
loud but like when my son gets out of
the pool and he's with his buddies and i
see my son kind of like shredded me i'm
like [ __ ] yeah yeah i do i do say it out
loud i look at like the fat dude to the
fat dad bods and i look at their their
kids that are lame i'm like
you guys know what's up you know yeah
you know look at look at my boy yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know my daughter's
just like this tank my two big girls are
brilliant you know and i like
i know we're not objective no but i
think what you're talking about for me
i've always looked at life as a bit of a
war like i i
i think beware of your cushy lifestyle
because the barbarians are at the gate
and they always will be always and
they're always coming do i need to like
drink out of the skull of my vanquished
foe maybe not maybe not but be ready and
be aware about my shorts right here that
your weakness and your softness is a
liability if you're not rehearsing in
your brain that's the way i look it also
comes in all sorts of different yes
whether it's online or whatever well you
and i but there's a different thing so
here's my problem like when i think
about like i love tough and all that but
being creative and being malleable and
being able to adapt to an ever-changing
world being able to learn unlearn and
relearn that's a [ __ ] that's
mental toughness that's standard form
i just shot my special life to throw the
whole [ __ ] thing away it's a form of
toughness it is yeah well adaptation is
the thing that makes humans the most
unique and the most evolved thing on the
planet right we got our opposing thumbs
we got our canines we have the sixth
sense of like is that an is that a lion
that's about like we have all of that
right we we understand math like
philosophy these these are things that
via adaptation we have evolved to become
the superior species on the planet can a
dude go and deadlift a thousand pounds
yes do we have people that go and run
the boston marathon at like four and a
half minute miles yes is that the same
species yes that's wild first of all
that is us but that's us do we have the
ewes and the joe rogans that can get up
in front of a thousand people and be
quick and witty and cunning and digging
sometimes or kind and clever yeah like
that's all can i can i do that no
you said that to me a long time ago when
you were talking about you you know that
there are guys that may not be built
like you but they can come into a room
and they can they they have such
technical proficiency they can collect
all the data on every computer in the
room or the guy the great thing about
your [ __ ] book when you're going into
if you don't read this book read into
the valley of death and return to the
valley of death that's all you got to do
the the [ __ ] don't read this book
leave yeah it's not
it's seriously upbeat about the book i
don't know but when but there's a kid in
there put down the back there there's a
shop leave the united states can i put
that on this yeah please okay seriously
i'm going to do like this
leave you don't read this book
get the [ __ ] out of my country gain
america yeah but but there was a kid
who was like he spoke greek he's just
[ __ ] shouting coordinates and he was
calling in the hedgehogs the ac 130s and
and you were talking about jtac
what is life so so he he like think
about an air traffic controller like
you're at lax that is coordinating all
the planes coming from all the different
airlines the different types of aircraft
the different altitudes that they have
to approach at the different speeds that
they have to approach at all of that is
happening but then you put weapons on
all of those planes and all of those
planes have to engage with clear lines
of fire with clear um coordination with
all other aircraft so you'll have an
aircraft doing an orbit then you'll have
fast movers that are coming in like this
then you'll have helicopters below them
then you have a10s that are going to be
somewhere in between those there's a lot
of room for error here yeah
and all of the different weapon systems
that each of those have imagine if the
the one orbeez that's like doing an
orbit yeah starts letting its gun go
like dude don't don't at the same time
the f-18 starts flying through
or the
apache helicopter comes through or the
a-10 comes to do a gun run right like
this dude is coordinating all of that
all the while he's communicating with
all of us as to where we're going
because we're on the ground right so if
i go the wrong direction so like this
dude is a savant like i don't know
what was that movie that brad cooper who
is so gorgeous bradley cooper
cooper yeah he like took a pill
yeah that dude was like a limitless dude
yeah he like took something
i couldn't they're a couple things i
couldn't i couldn't i couldn't
comprehend you're [ __ ] going over 80
trucks you got it you got to feed this
fob this ford operating base a year's
worth of supplies check this out
they get in there with 80 trucks they
get there
20 trucks that's right they lost 60
[ __ ] trucks 60. you know why the
iranian freedom fighters who are highly
trained [ __ ] not taliban
they're setting up ambushes they know
it's coming
and then you gotta you gotta answer back
they're shooting grenades everything
else that you and that's it
when you said that you would hear the ac
130s or the hedgehogs coming in and it
was like music it was the most wonderful
sound i've ever heard and i've heard
some wonderful sounds like the soft mo
moan of me doing the right thing yeah
good sound yeah you know
like hear that
the bert of yeah of the a-10 warthog
yeah but let me ask you this so you're a
sniper
you're a sniper in that situation yeah
you're literally it was literally i
haven't seen a movie with this kind of
action so you're a sniper
they're coming they're shooting at you
you've got position and you're taking
you have to take the enemy out from a
distance like that so you the whole time
you're looking for yourself
yes
how much sleep did you get in the in the
from point a to point
i passed out at a moment and i don't
know if i if it's over pressure altitude
sickness or if i just passed out but
there was a couple hours
that were
black
and and i don't know if i slept i don't
know what happened but there there's
periods of times where i was like i
don't i don't know what just happened
for the past few hours
no no no no i had like i bile and dead
dude all over the front of me yeah uh so
there was no like oh that was that was a
restful two hours it was more of like oh
my god we're back
you had to pull a guy out who'd been
blown in half oh yeah
that was that was another scary moment
oh yeah it's not a night no i'm in there
okay this is worse oh my gosh
i could wake up from a nightmare and
you're like oh
it was just a bad dream
now this is like you wake up you're like
oh i'm dude i'm i'm sitting first class
i have to be honest
i'm sitting first class swilling wine
and having having [ __ ] zucchini soup
on turkish airlines on my way to greece
and i'm reading your book and i'm my
girl's just watching a movie and she's
feeling great and they're would you like
more dessert would you like turkish or
would you like as i'm reading your as
you're in hell i'm reading this you're
telling me i can't feel like veal i kept
doing this to my girl i kept going you
got to read this just read this chapter
and she would read a paragraph
i'm trying to [ __ ] you're killing me
like i don't want to hear about all this
death i'm like the best part was this
you guys are in the middle of a
firefight they're in the middle of a
firefight they've just been through hell
the guy's trying to kill him resisting
this is in the valley of death they just
neutralized the enemy about 400 guys
where's the valley of death afghanistan
yeah in the ur is going probably so now
it's like now it's quiet it's never
quiet it's quiet now blood everything
[ __ ] up everything he's he's the guns
he's got a major headache he's [ __ ] up
the gunner comes down he's got a pistol
in his hand another badass guy like
mike's got a mic michael and he goes and
and tim because he's crazy at this point
goes what the [ __ ] you stand there with
a pistol in your your hand for you
[ __ ] idiot and the guy goes what did
you say to me and he goes get back up on
your [ __ ] gun because who the [ __ ] do
you think you're talking to when you're
gonna get a pistol because i'm talking
the [ __ ] i'm talking to the dick i'm
talking to the [ __ ] with a pistol and
then the guy goes yeah how about i come
down there and then tim goes you know
what's going to happen if you do in the
middle of this whole situation the quiet
professionals fist fight we're fist
fighting
does he have skills oh yeah and he had
just saved money though he just saved my
life
wild
and i don't know if he had like six
cents or whatever but he like
shoves me i mean
boom and i fly back from this door and
the door starts just shredding
762 just starts zipping through seven
six two five four pkm machine gun on the
other side of the door set up
the dude felt it
shoves me i fall back
the door just falls apart we go in i
throw a grenade through this window a
horrible thing happens
same dude i fist fight two days later
over him trying to get a pistol kill and
he's not sitting on his machine that
stud that's lack of sleep that stud died
he goes back to afghanistan yeah three
or four more times
dies december 20th 2019 on his like
sixth combat tour to afghanistan
is tim mike gobble tim that's a [ __ ]
thing where some guys have to be close
to the flame they get addicted to it
right
and they have to keep
being the dragon
or he's just chasing freedom it's
chasing the director where he's chasing
is it
okay could it be both see like that
could be [ __ ] like there is a
purpose there's listen just listen for a
second
there's a purpose thing here that like
if i lost the purpose i would be a crazy
person of course if i set like if i said
sore down if i if i wasn't fighting for
a thing a reason a belief
you know like the american dream if i
wasn't putting myself into that
i would be a horrible person i agree i
would take all of this energy and i'd
put it into like the most dangerous
thing possible i think what i mean is
that it's very difficult when you live
it when you live an extreme life like
that which is a heroic life which is
also a life that very few people touch
and it took a long time and you become
really good at that and you develop i
would imagine like you're saying
it's a sixth sense you develop you're
you're everything on your body
yeah and and but also the the bond you
make with people in that situation the
bond that you make
it seems like you there's nothing like
that right no it's the ban of brothers
it's it's true brotherhood right
and i i think the challenge is always
how the [ __ ] do you let that go well
there's also and obviously nowhere near
the same consequence but similar to ufc
too yeah like going through that like in
your training you're in your fight camp
you know and then you leave that and you
see these guys that become broken
struggle with like jason mann miller you
could not get a more picturesque
breakdown i love that guy
what a great person so much talent
that he became insane became terrible
became abusive you know like all the all
the bad things that can happen to a
human happened to him yeah like if he
stayed in the fight game you know was
not that there was redemption but
could it have prevented him from being
the terrible person that he became
the real sad part on jason mayhem miller
is
even outside the gun he had a special
set of skills he was he was very funny
charismatic charismatics clever loved
him clever and got a show on mtv like he
to me like it's such a sad story because
he had
his he could reach the [ __ ] stars in
this business i think it's possible and
i think that like in five ten years when
we know more about this stuff i really
believe we're gonna find that some
people with that kind of head trauma
just lose control of their brain
i [ __ ] knew it
i set them up but but then i lose
control too because i have t
so it's both of us yeah and we just kill
you guys you guys
you guys could do a lot of damage can
you imagine how much violence you got
like a tag team when i was with my
expert send me to russia i didn't know
him that well and he had to drop
something off my house and it was like
me and my girl were watching a movie i
had my i had my comfy there i had my
cozy stuff on and i i answered the door
we both answered the door and we're both
like this and my girl's like roughly
about you know this little shorter time
and we're just standing there like this
and he looks at us and he gives us the
thing and he's just looking at us and
we're all comfy in our little slippers
and we're all adorable and he goes
you know i could kill you both right now
uncomfortable they're way too close
he goes he goes right there right and he
goes i can go like that to your neck i
could squeeze your necks and kill you
both and your ex-wife didn't know me at
all she's like i think she probably
turned on now i think she was like have
a good night if you walk into
restaurants though and i look around and
and you know my grandpa's greatest
generation my uncles all were in vietnam
my dad stole plane fulls of cocaine from
pablo escobar like my brother is of fbi
bomb tech my other brother works for a
department of energy protecting nuclear
stuff my other brother's a green beret
you know i sit down i like and then i
like look at a restaurant and i go
like i'm not angry and i'm not thinking
about killing everybody in there but i'm
looking around me like i had to they're
so useless
they're so useless what are they gonna
do if i wanted to yeah what are they
gonna do but if but if the table's
flipped and they're like do what i'm
going to try to take that that dude's
two-year-old daughter i'm like first of
all i need to hide this erection because
you just made my day and i get to
protect my family and i've been training
for this for so long so i thought about
this every day every day to go to sleep
do you know what's now
what you're saying is that uh societies
that have been that have had the warrior
class at the top of the they don't do so
well and what's interesting about the
the genius of the founding fathers is
they said you still have to have a
civilian government in control of our
heroes our our our military because for
whatever reason that is only one kind of
strength and that strength is measured
and it's the kind of strength we love
it's superheroes the outliers but they
have the majority but there's also other
kind of strengths to your point like
where you're saying like there's also
you need your artists yeah and sometimes
you got to be soft to be an artist you
know you got to be you know he's he's
funny because as big as he is
i don't know if you know the story tim
but when we we had done dmt with aubry
marcus he took us through a shamanistic
mess with that no okay i won't give him
i won't even get an iso joe joe was like
hey you need to get one of these like uh
sensory deprivation tanks yeah i can't
be alone with my thoughts okay so if i
was alone with my thoughts with dmt dude
i did joe's isolation take i i jacked
off in it well yes he did all right all
right so anyway
we ended the podcast we just had the
podcast thanks a lot guys that's all
it's dark it's warm water dude i'm so
bored do you know i've never gone back
into those things because everybody
jerks off i'm the only one i didn't know
that are you an animal you [ __ ]
animal
uh now i'm glad i did it you know like i
was i was self-conscious that i was like
no like i'm not comfortable it wasn't
joe's it was in san francisco that joke
connection just common salt and i was
just just a bunch of common souls i'm
like how much
it's dark it's warm no wonder i float so
well i mean that's so boring sorry
viscous [ __ ] [ __ ] well this that's
the best story there's a filter what was
i talking about before you thought about
coming in right now oh so so dude
we do tmt with aubry marcus
and
when i say we saw sacred geometry and
went somewhere we did all right
so it's all good next day we do a
podcast with tim kennedy we didn't know
you were just excited i knew him before
yeah but i was you know i've always i
was excited and uh so we do our thing
you show us how to kill the first thing
you say is you want to say you killed
somebody with a knife i was like that's
good information anyways anyway not that
way anyway
sorry
sorry yeah
anyway anyway now
now check it out the next day we're done
with the podcast and he says he goes you
go i'm going back out in the field and
and you're like why and brendan's like
why
you could die and we both when we leave
we go he's the best we love him we love
him we're like a couple of school boys
who want to feel your muscles and we
think you're awesome so we're driving
and i'm talking to my wife at the time
and we're driving to aubrey marcus's
house to the park
it's a great house and he goes the
parties are dangerous before that he
says a couple things he's got sunglasses
on he goes he starts going i just you
know i'm worried about tim man i'm just
worried i go yeah yeah yeah i know he
goes and i said i want him to go off in
the field and just [ __ ] die i'm
talking to myself like this and i'm like
i'm like yeah i know i know i mean but
you know he's on the phone
yeah yeah whatever
yeah cool yeah everything's gonna be
fine so now i'm trying to explain
something i'm trying to explain
something
and also i just see him go
and this giant next to me begins to weep
and he's got sunglasses on really oh
dude and it's this and i and
i go it's not long now by the way i now
i pull up
oh brian goes can you not
oh yeah i go i go i can't i said i'm not
very sensitive i go i i have to go
because i have a [ __ ] weeping giant
to my right here and i got to figure out
what the [ __ ] is going on
and he's weeping i don't know if it was
the dmt and i think it was i'll tell you
what i want to hear
as he's as he's weeping like that and i
now now aubrey's throwing a snoop doggy
dog party i don't know if you've been to
those it's a snoop dog party yeah it's
just so i can't stop crying i tell brian
go go in don't let anybody know i was
crying i'm gonna tell him it's allergies
yeah he was all right dude i'll see you
there i walk everyone's like yo what's
up big [ __ ] crying like the [ __ ] i told
everybody i was like he's crying over
tim kennedy
then i got my payback because those
friends he has that he has that sand pit
out there and brian kept saying could
take me down and we ruined the party
because me and brian were drinking and i
go you can't take swim trunks you can't
take me down dude i go i'll give you
what do you want you can start however
you want try and take me down but i i
figure he doesn't think i'm going to go
double leg because he's too big nobody
would do that he doesn't know so i'm
going to go double that i've never seen
that before yeah so i go see whatever
you want brian and now like the girls
are around us and you can see everyone's
like oh these guys are what the [ __ ]
like we're trying to party i'm like
let's just figure this out and then
we'll be right back we could party a
second i just need to smash we're on
sand or gravel brian decides to shoot it
on a single leg and try to train wrestle
with a double leg and i i sprawled so
hard on his stupid old face
dude his dude i had his entire face
filled with sand red the contusions on
this side of my face just left yesterday
you can finally finally
parties are supposed to talk about like
licking frogs and like banging things
yeah not us yeah you were throwing axes
and [ __ ] what we haven't been invited
since no we haven't
no but i was thinking about why i was
crying about tim yeah and i remember you
talking about dmt i was like it was made
with dmt i could cry about tim it's not
dmt if you do love him yeah if you make
me talk about tammy and him pass away
i'll start crying
i i love you i got mad at me out there
since i talked about brace base jump
you're like don't do that you're stupid
pissed me off okay yeah i don't want you
to do it i think you're really important
tim and i don't want you to do any of
that [ __ ] i think you're that's why i
was talking about giving up the ghost a
little bit like i i know it's impossible
but i would really like to see you
transition into and you are doing it
with sheepdog response but to see you
transition i think you're needed as an
example and i think you're needed as a
[ __ ] uh guide for a lot of people
because you're one of those people that
understands nuance and you're not like
this black and white guy as much as you
probably had to be as an operator but i
think you're an asymmetrical thinker
which is why i thought the book was so
good and it was it was a testament to
that no we need you but we need to
forget america and the world your kids
ah i like that that's where i go i like
my kids and now that i'm a dad that's
where i go you're that's what you're
they [ __ ] yeah
but spartans don't spartans know all
that that's not enough on uh memorial
day i had
family over and uh
gold star
like yeah that dads aren't in the
picture anymore you know and oh cause
they
passed away in combat yeah yeah and yeah
you're right
so often you know we talk about the
spartan the samurai the warrior class
you know how often do we think about the
the second order of effect um all of the
women and children that are like left
behind it's wild we uh that's what's
it's a lot it's a lot
a lot and they all get together and i
see they share over that well they know
they try to
they try to survive they try to move on
um
so sometimes they're together sometimes
it's just sharing resources because like
now you're a single mom you know trying
to raise is there a system set up if
they pass away where they get funding
not really like
people forget it's so insane yeah people
forget that so
yeah i mean there's there's when you
your death benefits if you die in the
military in combat you know there's
enough to like live for a year or two
that's so insane but are you that he
that this dad gave up his life for your
freedom to go get a job families
not taking care for the rest of their
lives nuts
common sense yeah it's american men i
agree yeah
we're working on it the it but you know
not just
gold star families which are families
that lost somebody in combat you know
but mental health and suicide it's the
highest it's ever been in military
recorded history you know 18 to 80. why
is that military i mean it's high
amongst you know everyone but it's so
much higher in the military
well especially among like correct me if
i'm wrong we've never had this smaller
group fighting this long in theater for
that long that's right that and and
afghanistan well so
we've never had we have never had in the
history of this country we have never
had men small groups of men like him
engaged in combat for as long as they
are and when i say combat doing a lot of
killing on target there and so that will
weigh on any human being when you say
wartime because we pulled out of the
afghanistan war which is the longest war
right yep so america but then now
because we're not in the russia ukraine
war
we kind of are on our way
um yeah we're getting there we're in a
lot of wars bubba
we only pulled out in september of 2001
last year so you know we had 20 years of
guys getting multiple deployments
five six seven eight nine ten
deployments um the most susceptible
group to suicide is the 18 to 35 year
old just returning from combat like that
is the group that was the most and you
think like dude that's that's the war
combat veteran that just got back yeah
like that's the guy that is the most
like most vulnerable why is it because
they're out there like pursuing like a
mission or trying to accomplish
something they get back here and
what am i doing here
yeah like have you seen rambo like the
original og rambo yes where he's like i
could drive a tank i could fly a
helicopter you know like i am useless
here yeah you're like i'm i'm i'm
excommunicated i'm ostracized from this
community i i talk different i interact
different you know like i can't run a
business people don't hire me i got
tattoos you know maybe i got a scar from
a burn you know like i'm i'm definitely
scarred inside and out i think that it's
obviously a huge problem with uh you
know people coming back from tours and
stuff like that but it's also a huge
problem even with professional athletes
like if you look at the nfl the average
career is like three and a half years
you look at ufc fighters i think average
career last time like a year and a half
so it's like they dedicate their lives
since their kids to this one particular
sport then it gets over it's the same
there's this weird like
gray area where you're trying to figure
out because that's such a short chapter
your life so i'm sure they suffer with
it too yeah they absolutely do and
you're seeing a lot more nfl guys commit
suicide well you know the the like what
i have read about there's heard about
and talked about some other guys who are
you know gone through a lot of stuff
like that is that
the the problem is that you
nobody is built to be that close to life
and death all the time where it happens
over yeah for that long and i think
there's another thing that people don't
talk about but they've had but we may as
well since it's really helped a lot of
people a [ __ ] load of guys in theater
you know they've had a lot of help with
psilocybin and all that [ __ ] but like
this is a touchy thing to talk about
but i thought it was very important to
touch on
when you tell so a lot of young guys
that go into war let's say they're
operators they become really great and
they're going to war and they have a
linear idea of like right and wrong hero
coward uh america versus uh bad guys all
that stuff right and there's this idea
of nobility there's this idea and i
don't mean to speak to anybody who's a
veteran i'm just talking about it yeah
so there's this linear notion of uh
they're good guys versus bad guys i'm
gonna go do good things i'm gonna come
back a hero and i have plans okay
obviously war's way
way more messy than that way more
complicated and a lot of other things
happen that you have to do
and i think the the thing that nobody
actually ever talks about is there are
some people
because you're a human being
that
not only
get addicted to it
they start to
much to their own horror they start to
kind of enjoy it
they i don't mean to this is very touchy
so let me just explain what i mean they
you if you find that you you went to
church and you were a good person and
you do something and you find that you
kind of enjoyed it
what they've helped people do anybody
who's listening who feels these what
they've helped people do is people who
are clinical psychologists like jordan
peterson go hold on dude you got to know
something that's called being a [ __ ]
human being and everybody you know from
your priest to your father to all the
good to your second grade teacher
every one of those people
can do that there is a shadow side to us
and then there's a light side to us and
there are the angels of our lesser
nation and as long as they understand
that you're just occupying a all of us
have the spectrum and some of us are
pushed in that direction but once you
realize that that is that could happen
to anybody jordan peterson said it's
important to understand that you could
be a nazi prison guard and enjoy it and
until you get in touch with
that side of yourself
you will net like you know what carl
jung said for a tree to reach heaven his
its roots have to have to touch hell and
until you get in touch with that shadow
side that dark side
you will never understand what it's like
to be truly on the other side of that
and that's sort of the i know it's
touching i get a little i get a little
uncomfortable telling talking to you
about that stuff because i don't mean to
be disrespectful about being upset but
balance is is part of it right yeah you
know you look at the samurai and the
spartans they wrote beautiful philosophy
and poetry you know you have bonsai
gardens and zen gardens where they're
they're drawing art in the sand and then
they take a samurai sword and go up
dudes arm off
there's balance that has to exist there
yeah and uh some of the best
operators you know when we were talking
about mike glover you know like that guy
has a dark side to him you know he's
brilliant and he's a great human but how
could you not though how could you not
be in touch with the dark side and when
you're creative you better get in touch
with that
that's what they always say if you if
you if you want to be a writer like
stephen king or anybody you better get
in touch with the [ __ ] serial killer
in your body because you have them in
there do you mean my friend shane
steiner in austin yeah i love you yeah
stud i love that handsome guy i love him
what a stud i hate you so gorgeous
like your age
is he really he's just rich and
beautiful yeah he couldn't believe he's
one bad event away from being batman
you know he's just like he's good at
everything he's a great shooter he's a
great grappler and he was a special
force no country music singer oh yeah oh
yeah by the way and he sings i
he's the the bradley cooper i was
annoyed about how muscular and how good
looking he was but and cool i was
talking to him about about going back
into music and he was really reticent
because he's a good human now he's a
great father he's a good husband he's a
great training partner he's good at
jiu-jitsu he's like i don't know for me
like play and write music i was a
degenerate you know like i did drugs i
was an alcoholic you know like that's
the stuff that we'll talk about on in
front of microphones and all the other
terrible things that he did
i'm scared that that's what i have to be
like my roots have to go to hell yeah to
be able to to reach heaven again
well i think when you get older though
you find great creativity and enjoyment
in the in the in the battle of
restriction
i was never looking but there's also and
then you cut your ear off and paint
yourself yeah whatever i got to do but
every day
or whether you're a stand-up or you're a
musician that you touch that stuff that
you were doing back in the day when you
were wild as [ __ ] yeah trying to rattle
the cages well yeah because you go
through these phases where you go now
i'm going to be perspective now i'm
going to be a [ __ ] as disciplined as
i can be and even though every single
[ __ ] day i want to i want to go right
back to the old ways yeah you know and
it's like all right you know it never
leaves you i do like like talking to the
young guns see like the guys
up-and-comer fighters and they're
they're talking about like ah that's
like look at this ring girl
and i kind of like hey let's just come
up with me for two seconds let me just
give you some stories say how that could
happen yeah
i thought i had age you know let me tell
you something about this maybe not maybe
maybe not well i don't know if you just
take my book i don't see me hanging out
with you i'm not eight like
what what we're trying to hook up with i
know that's what i'm telling you those
chicks might be dirty well the greatest
part of your well one of the other thing
i loved about your book is how [ __ ]
honest you are you got two women
pregnant in the same month and then
another woman goes by the way i have
aids go get checked out so you're like
i'm gonna
die you get aids i don't have aids no i
didn't get aids
the only way you get aids
i think she was probably
drug use there was a there's a variety
of hooked up with a gay dude yeah so um
yeah it does not happen very often and
like vaginal stuff between male and
female she might have been [ __ ] with
you because you were off no no no no no
that wasn't so uh could you imagine me
at the gym though and like a girl walks
in she's like hey
at this fight at this night
we like had this orgy and um i'm just
trying to track down my partners and
you're like oh yeah yeah that was me and
she's like oh that was you and she
doesn't even remember you first of all
that hurts
right
and then second she's like
i'm trying to find all my partners
because i am positive with hiv i was
like
what you said yeah i'm sorry
all the balls
you lose your body no i would start
laughing i'm sorry you sound like you
said
are you
serious and so now here was this this
was uh 2 000
in 2 000 i mean so before you really had
protease inhibitors you're going to
[ __ ] die yeah
oh that's a good time so what happened
i'll tell you what happened he got naked
and gotten morro bay great whites
everywhere yeah
by the way
i did a b cold water so mike michael
johnson
blends money and injects it magic
johnson magic yes and then uh i just go
take my tiny penis and put in the oceans
how far did you swim because they took
the coast guard an hour to find you
so
i swim like a 28 30 minutes mile in open
water
so if so we're we're two miles out
that's what we are you're two miles out
yeah you're two miles out two more in
the middle of the ocean yeah that's lame
now wait a minute this is not developed
frontal lobe so to all the young women
out there that are talking to a 22 year
old understand that we don't work yet
we're idiots our brain
is [ __ ] idiot
not
in any capacity capable of any cognitive
learning i need to keep going back
though but how'd you beat the eight
yeah uh so for
he swam also
kills it
we
on that night in that orgy did just have
like regular sex and transmission of
aids doesn't happen right very as as
often as like anal or drug you know
actually actually it doesn't at all they
think barely
barely
yeah so how she got it i don't know i
didn't get into that yeah but i wouldn't
have any or any other part of her body
um
which doesn't transfer some of your hiv
nobody nobody was in her in your body so
nobody else as long as nobody's getting
behind are you into this it's premature
for you to know that for sure i didn't
cover that in the book
you know
but they weren't what a while dude what
a while my mom's my mom's bible group is
reading this book
and they're probably gonna listen to
this podcast it's the best book wait so
so let me ask you guys i never got it no
did anybody has a game get it nope nope
what a wild night right
there are some i could drop some names
of people that were in there that night
i would know them you know oh yeah i
can't wait yeah yep so
for a year i got tested every single
month i would have to go into the cuesta
college clinic
and
have an hiv so nervous jesus you're
negative you're negative you're negative
you're negative wait go and get the
blood wait it's not now like now it's
just like all right yeah obviously like
the military i have to do every year so
you got hit with the aid scare and also
two different girls pregnant yep holy
[ __ ] yeah my beautiful daughters they
had a couple of weeks apart yeah but
they are made a couple of days apart wow
yeah timmy was doing work and and i have
to go back to the open ocean because i'm
terrified of the ocean yeah you swam oh
shut up about the sharks uh you swam you
go in the middle of the ocean you just
swim out there
uh in that bay one of my mom one of my
mom's best friends carolee stewart died
in that bay and uh many many great white
shark attacks in the central coast area
what just happened three days ago three
days ago up there yeah really yeah and
you you don't you're not worried about
great whites you're in the middle of
their [ __ ] you're two miles out well
at the time is they hated my backyard or
they in my backyard
huh who's setting the sword down huh
do you think i don't think i want to
fight a great white dude i love it i'll
tell you a story when i'm in catalina
and avalon harbor
and uh great whites yeah a lot of great
whites and i'm swimming through the kelp
forest and i see a bunch of garibaldi
the most beautiful vibrant orange fish
you know what i'm looking at i'm like so
cool and then like a fart in the wind
they just disappear i'm like
where'd you go fish fish
fish there's no fish
and then i felt the water pressure
change
it felt like the water got thicker and
heavier
and they felt darker satan and there was
a there was a juvenile
shark great white i'm gonna guess it's
like your size so like nine feet
and i felt so helpless i went down to
the bottom and i sat there stuck in my
air like this
am i out of my regulator as i was
watching the psi of my my air gauge just
go like this and i'm down to like 700
pounds
and i know i have to go up it's probably
been 30 minutes i have no idea where to
go and i'm debating if i can walk or fin
all the way back to the beach or not
because i just didn't want to go up yeah
you're just not food to them though for
the most part but i feel like when
you're bobbing on the surface for
[ __ ] that long
there somebody's gonna be like he's
being a dick you're coming do i he's way
out my dick wasn't it was not on the
outside of my body because that water is
like 53 54 degrees also that's why they
say the biggest problem is the young
juvenile ones because they don't they
don't know yeah they've got the young
ones
there you go nope that's a person yeah
that wasn't good that's that's the fight
well now it's just a little little knock
so i went i was in morro bay a couple of
days ago and i walk up to that coast
guard station and the door flies open
like we're listening to you on joe rogan
right now
which was super cool and they're trying
to pull the log books to figure out who
the captain was the hub that think about
the audacity there's a dude that's butt
naked he's been swimming for an hour he
has to be hypothermic and he's he swam
all the way out a couple miles from
shore and you pull up on the boat and
you just start starts talking smack he
goes he goes what are you doing out here
tim's like i'm swimming
tim tells him this whole life story it's
a girl but i have aids i got two two
daughters coming i'm a piece of [ __ ] i
got kicked out of the [ __ ] cops i'm
not a cop anymore fire department kicked
me out i have nothing and he was like he
goes well that's the smallest dick i've
ever seen yeah you see what i was going
to offer to get out of the water
yeah totally cool just the coolest
cucumber and he knew what you were doing
out there yeah yeah i mean i thought
this was your goal my goal i needed to
be baptized
i needed to like feel
you know i needed to like
i don't know i
i wanted to
i wanted to not feel the pain of my
decisions i wanted to like
one be like clean and have a fresh start
and i don't know and this is where and i
have so much sympathy like there was no
point where
i was like i'm gonna commit suicide like
that was not going through my head
but obviously there's no level of
self-preservation this is where mental
health where we're talking about suicide
prevention and like how complex and
nuanced the human brain is where like
i'm going to swim two miles out into the
ocean like that is commute that is the
act of committing suicide yeah you know
but i was not trying not for someone
like you
exactly i was still swimming yeah and
and
could i have swim back absolutely did i
know which way to go no you know
you couldn't see the shore no i swam
into out in the fog
i didn't know which way the shore was i
didn't know which way the rock was i
couldn't hear the air horn and there
would be like sounds in the water and
i'd be like i don't know it's wet i
don't know what direction that is i swim
directly into the fog and fog does weird
things with your brain because i
couldn't it would like refract light and
and sound was like echoing what time was
it like five in the morning yeah you
would have figured it out though
it wasn't a suicide no it definitely
like to this day i still say
like mental health when you're in when
you're like breakdown yeah like
depression struggle like it's all
interlaced and intertwined so what do
you say to people who are
like that [ __ ] swim bro swim swim
keep swimming yeah you know like don't
go under don't quit i could have quit
right like i was cold i could have just
gone to the drink and like been wrapped
in the warm embrace of darkness but or
or
swim i don't think anybody who we admire
hasn't doesn't go through the desert
periodically and we're talking about
andy do that dudes face demons [ __ ] yeah
you know like serious ones and he's
stronger because of it 100 percent like
my mike
demons evan matt matt best and his
journey of doing some crazy things
arranger working with the cia like that
guy has some bad good looking yeah
he could do anything he wanted and he
he'd make a ton of money you know like
when he was making videos he's being
comedian he's great he could rap he
could sing play guitar gorgeous yeah i
know yeah and the coffee's [ __ ] my
favorite
my old girlfriend called me about him
she goes oh i need to meet matt best
he's the hottest thing i've ever seen i
was like i don't know what to tell you
what do you want me to do yeah all right
so at this coast guard station
they take photos we laugh we we kind of
shoot the [ __ ] for a second and then
ultimately i was like they're children
they're like 19 year old i don't know
coast guard ranks they're like an ensign
you know or like
you know they're they're all like
privates and uh 19 20 year old kids and
that and the salty old dog
saved my life and on the log you had the
date time group
so you had the date and kind of you
found the logic they showed you the law
they have it and it had
so like the time the date the location
and then the remarks which was
pulled a dude from the water that was it
one of the worst and most hardest
moments of my life was just a single
line that should be a lesson everybody
you're a you're less than a foot no
you're great
yeah yeah you're less than a footnote so
keep swimming keep swimming
and find help you know so that dude that
dude helped me he and he helped me in
all the perfect ways he throws this
cargo net down with my frozen fingers
and my tiny little frozen dick i clamber
up the side of the boat and then he
takes one of those wool navy blankets
and he puts it over my back and it felt
like a million needles of hot steel
burning into my flesh but it was the
best feeling ever
and as he's making fun of me and he gets
down he's like hey we're never gonna i'm
there we're never gonna have this
conversation again
you know it's like that that was it that
was the extent of like
tough love yeah there's no heart to
heart you know like let's let's maybe
like let me hook you up with a you know
counselor yeah you know let's let's find
some you know
some options in the church to figure out
how to no no it was i think everybody
did deals with it differently but i
think that's so [ __ ] true i love the
expression that that man in fact
speaking of hiv he won a tony award um
try to bring it up jin he's one of tony
award black guy he was 75 he was hiv
positive in 1989. oh okay
and he was gonna die uh and one of the
facts
he has become one of the greatest he's
when he is he is broadway royalty and he
uh mr rose no uh i will know his name if
i see it he made a speech it's on
instagram but it's so great because he
basically said people who asked who in
hollywood is h
yeah he said he said
no he's a broad just put broadway actor
black
i forgot charlie
anyway he [ __ ] he made his speech and
he said
surround he he just kind of said this
thing he speaks this way and he's really
you know and he's a great actor and i
think that's him happy i mean yes yes i
believe that's yeah whenever he made
this great speech
um and he basically said um
this is how it goes he goes surround
yourself he's an eighty-year-old man
he's a he's gonna be a messaging guy no
it's not him he's black um he said
surround yourself with people who light
up when they see you
the fastest way to get to where you want
to be
is slowly
and the top
of the mountain you just climbed is the
bottom
of
is is the bottom of the next mountain
so keep climbing and the way he said it
was just it was just [ __ ] beautiful
man i i didn't do it
no
okay [ __ ] i'm sorry guys it's okay it's
so good though he's he's older he's
really old
like you older i am 55 my fk i know is
so you're you're younger than that
yeah dude okay yeah dude thanks a lot
you're being a dick i just wanted to i
just want to make sure i understood that
age yeah time spent how old are you now
i'm 31. that's what i thought i was
going to say i was going to say i am 31
31
yeah
you sure you had a b yeah yeah he's a
famous famous uh broadway is it andre
the shields yes it is
yes it feels it is yeah just bring it up
because i want to hear
the shields yeah i know he's juicy
seriously he does the tough mudders with
me and crushes them yeah he's a big boy
there he is there he is
oh really he's off his body be like i
could survive off his substance for
a good four months
oh halfway through the tough mudder i'm
like man
like look at the elk i'm gonna shoot
that big one i don't really do it in
cannibalism but i also look at him be
like uh-huh yeah i'd be the guy
is that acl surgery on that left knee
yeah i see that scar i feel like
everybody in a war zone is just a nose
hair away from just
just eating another person you're just
[ __ ] this i'm [ __ ] your buddy just
being like you know what i love you so
much
those basic needs met
do it just looking at him i can see how
you
did the impression of how he does that's
right he speaks this way and he's he's a
great uh
broadway actor and he's wonderful if you
can find his acceptance speech it's
fantastic
there's a clip of it we only have to
watch a tiny bit
it doesn't matter
i'm kind of yeah i think we yeah yeah
you kind of ruined it yeah yep yep kind
of now i don't say it came the products
came to the screeching stop
looking for this guy nobody knows yeah
and he's at the bottom of the why do you
why do you know like the top of the
mountain you just climbed is the bottom
of the next one so yeah sure that's in a
dr seuss book
philosophical jordan peterson is going
to take it make it smart and then put it
into his book that's right that's right
that guy can write
that guy yeah who was you ever hear did
you hear him he was doing this he was
doing this thing it's like a tiny clip
and he goes uh he said you know people
are always
you know asking what is the antidote to
the discomfort of life and i suppose
you'd say it's comfort
but that is what a mother acts out when
she swaddles a baby another anecdote
might be an adventure to excellence
and that's the courage of a mother right
to facilitate that to encourage that
away you go kid away you go and the kid
goes no but it's dangerous out there and
the mother says yeah no kidding
it's more dangerous if you stay here
with me oh you go out there you might
lose your body you stay with me you'll
lose your soul you know he's all the
reels length videos of him on instagram
and youtube like that is that's the
idiot's guide to philosophy on my level
um i went and got his book like the 12
steps and as
it's too much
yeah there's too many words yeah the
print is too small i've also been there
yeah the same thing and i i got all fans
to myself like yeah i'd rather hear him
say it i think i'm a smart person and
then i'll read like
you you don't need it tim
but i do need it no you don't i'll just
go back to you
i read it you don't need it you live it
you live it i need it
like how the the google is just sitting
there staring at you have you seen uh
jordan peace in life he does those big
arenas no
he's coming any time yeah i haven't had
time to go into joe when joe got to
austin and i went to one of his comedy
shows the vulcan yeah that's the first
time that i've been to like live i've
had time to go to a live thing hey b
let's take a little break because we got
tim in here if you love freedom if you
love
we're about freedom dude if you love
freedom i'll be in fort wayne indiana
july 14 16. okay how about freedom fort
wayne in indiana san diego maybe oh dude
there's going to be so many military
guys there yeah san diego july 21st to
the 23rd then baltimore august 4th
through the 6th okay apple appleton
september 8th through the 10th i'm in
houston boston's all in september get
your tickets at thickboy.com or
f-a-t-k-z.com
but fort wayne indiana europe july 14-16
and that's san diego listen if you want
to see me live in my life you want to
see me hunting pythons yeah see me
[ __ ] getting waterboarded you want to
see me fighting special forces guy best
of that's the tv show on youtube go to
brian callan youtube channel uh i got
milwaukee improv july 21 22-23 i'm
excited about that austin texas tim
kennedy's hometown
july 28 29 30 and then i got nashville
tennessee zany's august 25 26 27.
spokane washington spokane comedy club
september 22nd 23rd 24th
excited that's a good run right there uh
hey dude how do you stay in shape your
legs are juicy yeah the juices it's
juicy you're you got a tail piece on you
you got you got big strong arms
some cats boxing no no no no daddy what
are you doing some calories with the
peloton man time and it's right in my
garage i get it done there it gets nice
and toasty in there listen i love
peloton they have great music whatever
you're looking for hip-hop edm rock they
got it all but do they world-class
trainers world-class trainers motivate
you 24 7. when you're ready to go they
have live classes which i like but they
also have the on-demand class so if you
miss it for whatever reason you got a
busy schedule it's on demand it's there
waiting for you i don't have an hour
dude i don't have you dude do you have
40 minutes you got 30 minutes you got 20
minutes you got 10 minutes yeah dude
they have workouts yeah really they have
it all man they have it all they got the
run if you have the peloton tread they
got the freaking 10 minute upper body
stretch between calls
yeah dude all right i like the tabata
ones with robin that's my favorite all
right and right now is the perfect time
to try out peloton the pelton bike plus
is now 500 buckaroos less it's the best
price it's ever been including free
delivery and setup and there are more
game changing prices available on the
original peloton bike which i have
you'll see me on there i've had for six
years um uh thick boy perez with z on
there that's my username follow me and
like uh and you can also get the peloton
tread as well visit onepelton.com to
learn more to go to a live thing i'm
gonna be at cap cities uh at the end of
july are you gonna be around i'll be in
ukraine [ __ ] fight for your freedom
i wanna know i'm fighting for them for
i'm not entirely sure it's just amount
of time for the game over here so yeah
it's wild that the new
the nato line is now at the border of
communist russia
like people haven't put that have put
that framework into their brain yet if
you think back to like east and west
berlin where like
germany
was the forefront of western
civilization and democracy and
capitalism was in berlin
and then on the other side of berlin was
russia
and then the wall came down
yeah mr goldberg tear down this wall
guess what
that has been encroaching
inch by inch
and then it's in belarus
ukraine crimea it's so bankrupt it's so
sorry to say it it's so 20th century bro
hey putin
are you annexing territory again they
are doing this are we going back to the
[ __ ] twenties they are though i know
but nobody's doing anything work out i
know no one's gonna how did it work out
he's literally he's about he's gonna go
all the way to the port you mark my
words
they're gonna get ukraine's gonna be a
landlocked country 80 of their gdp
happens through that port yeah they're
screwed yes now poland
finland romania
are all on the chopping i think that he
would be asking for and you would know
more about this than i do by far but i
think that nato has the weaponry and
technology to decimate a serious russian
assault in a place like poland because
they can remember this if they attack
sure they attack and they just took
ukraine but nato's a huge difference
ukraine is not a nato member the minute
they step [ __ ] foot in a nato right
and that's why putin said in 2012 the
idea that that that ukraine is flirting
with nato membership
is so antithetical to our it is it is a
direct assault on our national security
and if you think we're going to have
nato weapons on our border you're
certainly mistaken well now they have
nato weapons on their border yeah they
do he literally the hypocrisy of him
saying like i don't want nato on his
calculation
no he did exactly what he thought he was
going to do he just moved instead of
having nato come to his border he moved
his border to nato
so in in the aggressor that's
interesting
he's not dumb he's not done he's not
done they also say he only has three
years to live
do what a tyrant can do in three years
that's what i'm saying yeah i mean i
could get a lot done if i was i think
it's scared that he was three if he
actually has three years i think he
wants to be this is a fancy bottle yes i
could use this as a weapon yes welcome
to thick boy yeah
he could kill somebody with that oh yeah
or the mic
but i think what's scary if he does have
three years he wants to be like cemented
in history yeah so what's him
going to stop him from releasing the
news well i don't think there's any
profit in that right so so i think he's
a he's he's a cold calculated guy who's
looking at the like there's there's a
strategy and a method to the madness
right so now ukraine belongs to me now
ukraine is no longer going to be a nato
member right and
there's probably some there's probably a
lot of
profit in something like that where you
can control history and profit though
because the oligarchs are on the [ __ ]
run now and they and the overdrafts
control everything i'm sure there's a
cost for skin analysis of like what is
this land worth what is the production
that's happening on the east side what
is this poor port worth like 80 percent
of a country's gdp is that more than
i look what happened to oil prices when
russia this is a flow chart for me to
make before i started making decisions
about how deep into this country i'm
going to go i'm i'd be like all right so
i would take this manufacturing this
industry i would take this uh mining i
would take this amount
not stupid no he's not going i'm gonna
do this forget the money he's gone if we
get this especially that port and i
would love to be there at the end of
july but do you think that there's
anything i know it bums me out but do
you think there's anything we're going
to film that thing too no i can still
make that happen really yeah i want to
shoot i want to shoot a best up with him
where i'm shooting [ __ ] hogs from a
helicopter what can we can we shoot him
on horseback that is really hard okay
yeah i'm not gonna we're not made for
that no i ride you should do what you
should do what i wanted to do with tim i
want to get waterboarded
and i do that in a heartbeat the problem
is i told him that and then when i was
in austin last he texted me goes hey
heard you want your water board how
serious are you i'll do it for best
stuff okay you save your address you say
that but okay so hold on
no no no
i look more into it i'll do anything for
my [ __ ] tv show he'll do anything for
the views so i think brian might do it
and not only that i want to kill hogs i
want to blow [ __ ] up and i want to be
water boarded now okay the first two are
super easy the third so for for
waterboarding to really work in this
advanced interrogation you have to like
have full confidence that you're not in
control
so yeah if if you know that i'm limited
to okay i can only expose you to this
duration of water at this angle then
you're like okay i'm safe that's not
what's gonna happen you're gonna get all
right so ready okay you're gonna use
your safe words and i'll be like i don't
give a [ __ ]
and then you're going to do the thing
with your hand to let me know that you
reached your break point and i don't
give a [ __ ] after that timmy's going no
seriously tim i'm about to die yeah you
still don't give a [ __ ] okay that's why
i'm not doing it i don't want to that's
just that
mike lover i hope michael can make it
they're going to hunt me i'm going to
have a i'm going to air soft and why are
you going to hunt with them but you're
not going to let me honey i'd love you
too if you if you want to come and join
those guys i'm going to get three comics
no no we want him he's too tough i'm
gonna get like i can't you're two i need
guys like dalia and nix watson i need
guys and we're gonna try to [ __ ]
fight you guys for real i'm gonna have
my weapons and we're gonna [ __ ] we're
gonna try to
airsoft with you and kill you fine line
between dumb and crazy is really getting
blurred right now so yeah so we are
gonna chris thank you sign up for that
[ __ ] chris
with his spear operators like elite if
you lose you get waterboarding
you're gonna you're gonna wake up and
there and mike glass are you gonna hit
me all over no he's gonna have like pig
blood sprayed across his face and you're
gonna just you know you're gonna wake up
and he's gonna be hanging over mouth
breathing you know and a couple of your
toes you're gonna be hanging from his
earrings dude i called andy stuff he
goes i i got he came back with a date he
goes how's the [ __ ] beginning of
august you [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm like here
we go it's gonna be savages those she's
gonna be in the brilliant squirrel suit
flying through the air like that
sounds like so much fun i just want to
see how long it's kind of fun wait i'll
tell you yeah
do they know where you're at like i
don't know how it works
figure it out it's going to be safe you
guys are going to last one minute well
i'm going to try to i'm going to try to
[ __ ] squeeze off some rounds bro
look at him look at him look at him look
at that she wants to get waterboarded
just do that okay so how long do you
think i could last realistically water
being waterproof so the the question
isn't how long you could last on the
board the question is if there's
something i want from you yes how long
is it
are going to tell me okay and
i'm going to people reach a point where
they will say anything
even if it's not true
to get off the board
wow
i believe that it's so like i could tell
you i i want you to say
i believe that unicorns are real and i
had
intercourse with one of them yeah that's
the sentence i want and you're like
first of all they're not real second
there's no bestiality in me that looks
at a unicorn it's like that's what i
want yeah there's not a bit
not a problem and i can't you're still
gonna say it and i can't and what
happens is you're drowning you just
can't breathe but you're not dying
you're drowning and you are dying you
are dying yeah you're that close so
you're just gonna keep pouring water and
you're not letting me [ __ ] no no no
and i'm inverted but you give me breaks
obviously no no i mean depends on what i
want to do
and i'm so i got to but you're already
grasping for the rational safety
measures that are in place and i'm
telling you there's no net that's not
how that's really [ __ ] scary because
i'm already i'm i'm getting
claustrophobic thinking about it
i'm claustrophobic yeah the wet towel
over your face you know the water at the
angle that you're at going back up into
your side i saw you get down trying to
you're trying to blow it out yeah do you
see my friends that were using a bucket
they're like forget the bucket they pull
a hose out yeah use the hose yeah those
are my friends and they're trying to
break they're they're horrible they're
not real friends did they break yourself
you can't break it right i'm just gonna
say someone can't break a rock
so horseback we have tried the javelin
spearing horses off horseback horses get
super spooked right around pigs because
they smell weird and you don't think
that we're crazy people we are true
conservationists i'm talking like we
love
i love protecting wildlife i just want
to eat a pig
we're not eating these pigs oh you're
not no you don't eat them they're not
good
well they're trash pigs they're gross
trash
are they why come on dude because
they're disgusting they're they're
they're like the rats right but still
they're wrapping it's still yummy pork
and bacon no there's no there's no bacon
there's no fat on them they're all
muscle no no they're all like worms and
pesticides or pesticides and disease and
rat poisoning oh trash pigs you like cut
one open there's like this weird blue
meat you're like what is this like oh
that they ate some poison they ate some
poison out of a field and like oh just
turn their meat blue like yeah yeah you
don't eat that part
wow and then you like cut a little bit
more and there's like maggots crawling
out of their skin you're like yeah
yeah [ __ ] that zombie trick gnosis and
[ __ ] there's nasty they're nasty they're
they're rats of texas and they they they
[ __ ] breed at such an alarming rate
you can't you can't shoot your way out
of it they they become
fertile
so young and they can have so many
litters and each one in a year they can
have multiple litters in a year and then
every one of the litters they can have
like eight ten twelve people i watch i
watch on youtube they shoot them with
night vision just they shoot with
everything and there's not enough like
there's not enough shooters we're not
stopping them they're still mass
producing it is wild we went i went
python hunting in the everglades because
it's a big thing yeah we got an
11-footer did you um yeah did you find
it [ __ ] great
awesome one of my dreams
i want to be riding
a motorcycle over like this overpass
over the everglades you know there's
like overpass over overpass and i see
because you just see him for a heartbeat
yeah it's a thousand dollars if you get
them too for the skin yeah and just like
don't ditch my bike and free fall under
the back you don't know how big it is it
might be four feet yeah it might be 40
feet yeah and jump on the back splash
they're so strong
they're all muscle yeah you got if you
get an 18-footer you can have your hands
full tim kennedy even tim kennedy's
gonna have his hands full i said 40 feet
boy 40 feet i know she's got a 40 feet
away but how would it kill is it going
to kill 10 by now though if you i mean
it's not because you're going to grab
his head don't bite the [ __ ] outty a big
one a fully grown and
their heads are bigger than your head no
they stay on that show uh the toughest
bite or whatever on the channel
last episode season finale they get bit
by all these like bugs and [ __ ] last one
they get bit by a python yeah the guy
puts his arm it destroys this python
capital he caught an 18-footer in the
everglades 18 feet that's the choice
bro it bit him and and opened an artery
yeah yeah and he was
almost bled out yeah and then he took
him he wrestled it he's by size he's not
a guy your size but it dragged him into
the swamp it took him an hour to wrestle
i think it's all off it's on youtube
he pulled him into the water
that's what i'm scared of well there's
still here
the 11-footer i couldn't [ __ ] get
what do you want just a thousand bucks
well that thing's worth a lot more
that's how he makes his living but there
are major invasive species they're a
huge problem the everglades yeah so they
just pay people to go hunt them all
these invasive species may like
they're fun to hunt but people don't
understand how damaging they are to to
where they're going you're like yeah
let's just say you're a duck hunter and
you're looking at what is happening
along the florida um mississippi
louisiana coastline and
destroying the deer population raccoons
they're taking nutrients out they're
taking all of them destroying everything
the ecos the the micro ecosystems of
each of these respective little tiny
states are just getting demolished by
these finally though finally the animals
the birds of prey and stuff are starting
to go play back
here's what's really [ __ ] up in burma
they have 40 eggs for whatever reason in
the everglades they have 80. what yes so
now what they're doing now the osprey
and the hawks they're going you know
what
those are eggs and now they're finally
figuring out there's food here and now
they go those little snakes that's food
too so they you know i went squirrel
hunting in nashville with hawks
the hawks would [ __ ] catch they just
kept catching snakes squirrels they kept
grabbing snakes huh or squirrels of
problems
no but it was a thing i got for
valentine's day and
you went hawk hunting
you took hawks and hunted yeah and i
felt bad
i didn't want to kill the squirrels
because i i'm not going to eat the
squirrel so i i didn't like it so on my
folks property we we we massacre
um ground squirrels
because they they make holes the horse
step in and the cows step in them
ground squirrels
no it's it's a ground squirrel oh it's
an actual squirrel it's a squirrel that
lives in the ground yeah and uh they
it looks like a groundhog yeah but no it
looks like a tree squirrel that lives in
the ground big bushy tail yep
you hunt you hunt yeah yeah right there
you're a hunter what's going on
the num number three is like the most
akin yep that's the right one and that
yeah yeah the big fat one oh man
like how to control ground squirrels
dude that guy right there
what have you what animals have you
killed probably just this might we have
to have this out but also if you think
about squirrel those big bushy tails
kind of like a peacock squirrels are
just like transgender rats
they're just like
you have to have that out chance do you
i don't know do we have enter that no i
don't think it's fantastic yeah i think
it's a beautiful fantastic um
observation i just think it's an honest
observation and i don't think it's and
if people are offended transgender
activists are probably not watching the
fighter and the kid and they're probably
not reading scars and struggles they do
i hope they do yeah i hope they read i
think there's some great takeaways for
all race religions not that pretty that
that guy i hate that guy right there
that guy's gonna don't know no yeah he's
gonna break my horse's legs [ __ ] kill
him one of my steer man we we did this
uh rib roast a couple nights ago that
was one of the steer on my dad's
property
like we raised it yeah
grain fed the last 90 days it was
grass-fed its whole entire life wow you
know it's like walking around with wild
tully elk wild pigs you know up in in
monterey county california and uh and
then
for my my niece's high school graduation
which happened this weekend
we cooked a rib roast
from one of our from one of our cows
it's rad
it was delicious oh so good you know
what once what sporting event tim can't
do
football there's lots well there's but
there's one thing he's not good at he's
right he's not football no you have to
leave you can't throw a ball
so guess what you learned ryan
let me tell you how wrong i am do what i
just did on this book tour
i threw the first pitch
what for one of the uh did you hit the
catchers in the blade no
aaa
like uh like right before they go to the
pros harder than it looks right
well i'm not gonna dignify that question
which was kind of insulting with the
response i'm gonna go a different route
here i took me one day i threw a 62 mile
an hour fast bar oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
and uh that's almost like i took a day
to learn how to do the whole wind up how
to on the pitcher's mound how to place
your foot on that little rubber bar yeah
because you're up on a
mountain you can like whip yourself you
can use gravity to fling it yep what is
that
oh no nice i don't know
oh i just look at you
i just posted you you're so you're a
gorgeous man what are those little stuff
those are hippos why are those little
hippos in your back because that's in
the bathtub um so i have a lot in common
with hippos i i think they're in my
spirit animal when i look at all the
similarities like if you did a venn
diagram between tim kennedy and a hippo
like they like the water true they're
thick
they're thick they like their family
they're kind of territorial
you know they're they'll murder you
they'll murder you you know um you you
mess with their family they're gonna
take it's on they're gonna kill you and
everything near you
have you ever seen like the videos of an
alligator that gets into a group
crocodile yeah they're like you just see
like a parking alligator flying through
the air well how about the how about the
gazelle the gazelle's trying to run away
from the [ __ ] wild dogs the girl's
like these wild dogs i'm gonna i'm just
gonna sit in the water
hippos over here and i'm just gonna hang
out here because they're trying to eat
me if you don't mind and the hippo was
like well here's the problem you're in
my water it's my water yeah and you're
on fifth street bites it around the
[ __ ] neck and just
and then they just toss it drowns it or
they stomp them out oh god i enjoy good
stuff brutal so uh so you're baby hippo
there's a there's yeah i just i just i
sympathize with them yeah and they get
they they get a bad rap also that's
another kill the most humans out there
yeah they kill a lot of people
mosquitoes yeah yeah you like the way
this feel
they feel so good
he should be your model for this and i
swear to god did you think my feet are
okay with that though i i i love it
because i got that i got the rust i got
the been wearing too many wrestling
shoes yeah so it goes in yep
wrestling shoes are really you wear them
really tight that's why i want your feet
i want your toes splayed that's what i
that's why i wear it but because you see
how you're like skinny and dainty and
then his are like he's got he's got
trophy but that's what you want for your
model yeah we're the people that like
have obsessions with feet there's a
whole
subculture
well because we there was a lady in this
seat named cat she started only fans of
her feet she made so much money she she
quit yeah
yeah yeah people love feeding it's wild
she made so much money
if i start a fans only for my feet dude
we'd be like
we should we should hire you as our
model
kennedy mountain models foothold people
you know
owns nine pairs tim uh i mean uh andy
stumpf he's getting married and he he
ordered
he ordered a bunch of blue crocodile
saltwater crocodile i don't know if i
could for his wedding or his whole
wedding party are wearing blue
they're all wearing touhou i hate him
i'm supposed to go hunting with him
still haven't hunted with him i'm
supposed to go on a podcast have been on
podcast he's opening a black rifle i
didn't get the invite i don't know if
it's open yet i don't know i didn't know
i supposed i've always done jujitsu with
him one time when he came to austin and
i had to have him come to my gym yeah
for him to do jiu-jitsu
he's a purple ball i think he's not at
tim's level but yeah
that's tough no i don't know what you
can't say that anymore because i'm in a
room where everyone's better than me so
i don't know are you being modest though
wait wait yeah compared to those guys
that's all they do though that's their
language yeah i i don't know i like that
you're trying to assume that i'm being
humble i've seen you have honest
everybody i'm saying i can there's a
difference between hanging yeah and then
like gordon and ryan being like hey i'm
gonna roll with you because i'm cool
different thing right yeah right
freak gordon ryan like when he rolls
with me he rolls with me to be cool but
he could kill me at any moment
he's so mine he's our lebron james with
jiu-jitsu levels levels of the game yeah
but me and him yes
but then you got like the stephen
curry's who go and they'll hit an
outside shot on on lebron james nobody's
going to hit an outside shot no on
gordon ryan nobody's going to do it no
there's nobody that's going to touch him
there's nobody that's going to score a
point on him he'll walk up and hand this
you know fabio dude over here with like
this is how i'm going to choke you he'll
hand it to you he'll go and hand it to
the refs and then he'll go beat him with
that
without because he gets modest but i've
seen him tie up some really good guys
you be honest yeah be honest okay like
he's in a blast for 30 years yeah he's
not doing that to you 30 years uh
15 i've been a black belt for 15. you
know how
grappler so my feeling is that so he
could do that to you yeah coordinator
right yeah yeah oh dude everybody in
this room you just don't know the levels
of jiu-jitsu
i've seen it a little bit not going
right yeah at a high level and even like
what is it just his just the hierarchy
of he's the tip of the spare yeah and he
he makes a living i just feel like a guy
i've seen that much like you guys have
seen that doesn't work like that it does
that's all he does it's literally all
he's consumed in it [ __ ] it but it's all
he does and everyone on the mat is like
that
everybody on the mat is like that no no
real cool
how about him he's teaching uh a
sheepdog response yeah i was watching on
youtube and he gets the guy and he's
like this he takes his finger and he
goes you're blind you've never seen your
kids again
i'm like tim you know but that's that's
real funny yeah he's got the guys he
goes like this he's in class he goes if
i see anybody pull a guard in here i'm
gonna i'm gonna send you right through
the [ __ ] wall
garden he's just beating me this is
light like life jiu jitsu
sports jiu jitsu guys will come in so i
was in new york teaching a self-defense
course and we had guns like training
guns and knives all over the mat and
this angel gracie guy dives underneath
and is trying to grab a leg lock and i'm
sitting here with a gun and he's still
like digging trying to get an angle to
try to get a hill hook and i'm just like
with the gun tapping him on the forehead
yeah and he like looks up and he like
you see the focal shift from like my
face to the gun and then like back to my
face and then you see the realization
like it actually connects with the
myelin
the the neural receptor so used to known
for jumping from knees yeah and i'm
sitting here tapping him on the head
with a gun and she's still like trying
to play with my ape legs and uh he like
looks up he's like
like yeah man that's not gonna work your
happy place is not good here so there is
a big
when we're talking about tear and
tactical and shooting can the sport
shooter become a combat shooter
absolutely the huge overlap tons of
great shoot sport shooters become combat
shooters and combat shooters also
compete in sports
could a really great grappler transition
and be a really great mma fighter
absolutely could a really great mma
fighter go and hand him a brick and
become a savage yeah you know but but
guys that becomes so pigeon-holed into
like the exclusivity of the sport aspect
they're in trouble they're in trouble
across all them
like those guys are die-hard jiu-jitsu
guys go to mma and they don't work on
the other stuff and it's just jujitsu
they get i mean hidalfo vieira
bushesha
chrome gracie like you look at the tip
of the spare guys hodge or gracie
you can't do all of it
eventually you come along and you [ __ ]
up to your point like you know tony
blauer oh yeah tony's a buddy of mine
tony tony was teaching uh so this this
air marshal was grouping shots just bump
about just an amazing shot with a pistol
right and tony goes okay good good now
he gets behind him and he goes now i
want you to do the same thing
and
go ahead but at some point i'm going to
hit you
and the guy was like what you guys
i'm going to i'm going i'm not going to
hurt you i'm not going to hurt you but
i'm going to hit you i'm going to grab
you somewhere i'm going to i'm probably
going to hit you in the back at some
point but just go ahead and do this
or like well i mean it's really running
back
now the guy the guy he can group air
marshals he'll know they can group any
pop-up they can just see right and now
he does the same thing his shots were
[ __ ] all
you added one external consideration you
you you take a guy out of a vacuum that
can perform just in the parameters of
what he's comfortable with yeah can that
like if i take a racehorse
get somebody getting ready to go to the
derby i've been talking to the most
elite thoroughbred race horse and i take
him to war what's gonna happen to that
horse he's not gonna be the first horse
no he's gonna be dead he's gonna be dead
like he's gonna go he didn't get that
good warm up he didn't get his good
grains you know and and the steroids
yeah it doesn't have any of it it's
broken in a heartbeat and that that is
it's performing in a very specific way
in a very specific modality in very
specific considerations in very specific
conditions
like similarly with like the the combat
shooter or the fighter like or the sport
jiu jitsu guy if he doesn't have
the
all of the conditions right for him to
be at his best like is he is he really
that useful in the combat sense well in
your book when you had a guy's body
you're whole you're trying to save a
life they're shooting at you you don't
have this you're not doing this you have
one hand trying to squeeze off rounds no
i had my sniper rifle i had an sr-25
sniper rifle with the suppressor sitting
on the end of it with a 12 to 20 long
stick yeah i'm like i'm like this as
these dudes are running across as i'm
carrying a half a body that's dumping
bile blood and poop all over me
and uh that was bad
yeah bad thumbs down thumbs down on that
huh no can't still say the dude's name
yeah his name is mike k
mike k was sitting on a modus 50 cal
machine gun on the back of a humvee and
when i jump out and i run down to the
humvee that just got blown up and i'm
dragging this guy's body out i didn't
want to go down there by the way this
other guy irish ran down there to get
these guys out and i was like don't do
this
no please no yeah and he goes anyways
because he's a total hero and so i
didn't want him to go by myself so i go
with him and we get down there and when
you have an ambush you have a kill zone
and we were on the kill zone we got
blown up everybody pretty much died the
few of us that made us off the kill zone
we are now running back down into the
kill zone which is not where you want to
go the last thing that you do in an
ambush is you assault if you're the one
initiating the ambush you assault across
the ambush line killing whatever is left
there so we run down to try and rescue
the guys that are on the kill zone and
i'm trying to pull his body out and
these guys the taliban the iranian um we
i called them freedom fighters in the
book and i really regret that i called
them that because i know that's what
they call themselves fighting for
freedom they're not they're just
[ __ ]
yeah just horrible people but they're
highly trained they are operating and
funded by iran yeah and uh
sulaimani who we killed um a couple of
years ago he was the guy that was
funding them yeah so i get this body out
and i'm trying to get this guy and i
can't get my gun around i'm gonna die
for sure and mike k
with the 50 cal he i don't
divine intervention he was able to weave
bullets that are like this i felt like i
was getting hit with chuck liddell
overhand rights as these rounds were
flying past my face because you can feel
the the energy the overpressure as these
rounds are going around and through us
and between us and
vapor like there was there's a bunch of
talibans over here and then there
weren't and it wasn't like in the movies
where it's like pink mist i'm just
saying they
they have evaporated they just
disappeared off the face of the planet
50 cal machine gun and he wasn't but
like 100 meters from me
threatening rounds that's that accurate
what a battle was he a special forces
guy oh yeah oh yeah yeah mike
yes yes he was but he's just he's
awesome
i love you bro love you thank you for
saving us yeah that is [ __ ] well over
time over pressure because i never
thought about this either you you had
such a concussion from just the sounds
and the i guess when bullets are close
to you they they move matter or like
they they what do they do they displace
air yeah so when you're shooting a
sniper bullet you can uh so as as the
bull is traveling through the air you
can see the air be displaced by that
bullet so let's just say i'm shooting a
seven six two seven six two by five one
a 0.308 so that's a 175 grain bullet
that's traveling at 2 650
feet per second
so that is a chunk of metal that's 175
grains traveling at almost 3000 feet per
second how much
vapor is that going to displace yeah you
know how much air is going to be moved
air has matter in it yes right so as
that matter is moving like dust we call
it trace
the the vapor trail of that bullet i i
can see exactly where that bullet is
going to go well that is a bullet that
is only
175 grains you get up to like a 33 338
lapua now we're a 250 grain bullet you
get up to a 50 cal i'm talking like a
bullet that is this big it's like a
battery yeah
yeah chucking a d cell battery at 3 000
feet per second yeah you can you can you
hit somebody at a mile away and they
kind of
yeah now b you were talking about him
being your uh model for uh to hold now
here's small problem i don't know you
guys budget but i'm his manager yeah
what the [ __ ] this is this is i don't
know if you know how much money daddy
makes i need a couple i'm gonna talk
about it unless we got eight figures yes
two comments all right yes you need two
two comments you just small commas two
commas two comma two sorry that's
something two comma two i'm the kind of
guy around here can i get can you be
castle let me tell you guys video
totally inside video of you in combat
with those [ __ ] things i love these
so much i can't wait to represent these
these are going to be fantastic
he loves them they smell like satellites
too that's top grain leather two cup of
tea vegetables
all natural
two comma ten yeah maybe you know what
you're [ __ ] and by the time we sign
the deal he'll be on new york's uh
bestseller i'm already m okay well now
we're talking about three comments two
two weeks in a row there's three
comments what number one audiobook on
the planet still i mean what do you want
to do okay well can i can i do a layaway
plan yeah
yeah i like this harley i like this
badass version i'm scared actually can
you imagine being on the opposite end of
the table negotiating with brendan shaw
he's very good very good man actually
i'm a little i'm a little bit i'm i it's
a good cup back up i play back up
because i hate everybody
if i like crawled over brandon and tried
to kill you right now yeah who in this
room would come to your defense well
first of all marx might jump out first
of all what i would do is i would look
in your eyes i would get into the i
would get into your human side
yeah yeah
right
kill him tim i go nobody
i love my children
just accept that i go god bless america
you know what i do there's the greatest
story remember this the the the
the uh feudal
shogun he comes into the town everybody
was supposed to leave the town when he
would come in his samurai would be
following his ronan would follow him and
and he would kill everybody anybody who
didn't have they'd prepare food have the
town empty and if you anybody was there
would be killed one day he's coming in
this buddhist monk is sitting there and
the buddhist monk is in you know his
lowest position and he goes i'm not
leaving they go you eddie your mind is
going to kill you and he goes i'm not
leaving he's in the middle of the road
the shogun comes up on his horse his
whole army behind him and he looks at
him and goes
uh do you know who i am i am the one who
can cut you into a hundred pieces
without batting an eye and the buddhist
monk looks up and says and i am the one
who can be cut into a hundred pieces
without batting an eye did he kill him
he didn't he let him go oh that's what i
expect from the story would have been
cool because that's hard dude i'm gonna
go the other way yeah i'm gonna go the
other way look dude how are you gonna
[ __ ] come at me right now yeah
humanity without much eff effort dude my
heart is [ __ ] up
you're gonna be so guilty
that story makes tim want to kill you
more yeah do you mind you know one time
i was joking around i said i said to him
i go i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
grapple with tim and and he and you you
you thought i was serious he went like
this no no no no like that he goes no
he'll kill you i was like i'm [ __ ]
joking dude i'm not gonna actually we
can't totally grapple though yeah you
could yeah i'm a little delicate you'll
hurt my neck or something like his neck
up jen what are you doing i'm just
making sure if you guys do a fight
oh no yeah i'm not going to join tim
kennedy
tim wants to tim wants to kind of i do
he was just cuz he wants a water board
being beat me up because i'm just i'm
i'm just such a target right now when i
got to calabasas i i was looking for a
juice i was looking for a gym i was like
i didn't bring a key for nothing i have
all today so i could wash my key before
i get to know i'm going to talk about
the bear a little bit i'm putting my
fingers in there i feel it i know you
keep you trying to keep giving me these
backhanded clothes i do it too nice
thing but i'm like i'm going to hit you
the back of my head to me i
his face and then i slap his face again
is your son in jiu-jitsu oh yeah
yeah loves it yep he likes to cross more
do you do you have a pro like when you
go because i'll have to take my son
jiu-jitsu after this yeah when the
coaches are coaching
used the coaches as a way to actually
communicate to his stupid son oh
interesting and uh because you would
fight him i i was just so rebellious i
was such a second born i was so stubborn
you know
and uh and and you must have been a pain
in
respect for coaches they're i i don't
know
if coaches really understand how
important they are right now in this era
i agree you know in in participation
trophy and no no no no i know you lost
but you did really great out there no
you didn't no you know like be better be
a real coach and be like do you know
what you didn't practice you weren't
doing your wall ball drills right you
know you weren't out you didn't get here
on time you didn't do the warm-up that's
why and then you're mad at me because
you're not playing like those moments
are so important right now and uh and so
i look at my son even though he is a
great and even my daughter who's doing
jiu jitsu um and i let the coach coach
and if i have to coach through the coach
i do that but then if i need to give my
son a little extra okay so a snap down
isn't it you pull on the back of his
neck it's called a snap down
pop the back of his neck and bounce his
forehead off the mat yes that's how you
do a snap down see my son he's such a
good listener he'll listen to me listen
he's getting into a team to a t that's
awesome i'll go uh baseball grip when if
someone has backing like two on one over
he's coachable he's [ __ ]
wow
that's coachable yeah yeah i mean i was
too dead tim was talking to himself
there you snap his [ __ ] neck down you
take his face you make soup yeah you
make superman
his teeth on the mat success right some
of this
spinal fluid yes
you're doing this
color it's kind of creamy
yeah he gets intense yeah that's right
you're looking at me like i'm [ __ ] a
gazelle and you're alive you keep
looking at him you're acting you look a
little carnivorous right now dude i
don't we don't like your initial offer
from toehold
i didn't even give it all i'm just
saying
numbers bump them numbers up i'm gonna
bump it up i just want your feet to
spray out a little you're you're wearing
shoes that are bunching your toes i need
them there you go
yeah yeah i'm i am looking i'm gonna
wear those other shoes too those are
nice yes i'm done i don't i actually
don't own like a pair of nice shoes like
that i figured you didn't i owned one
dude that was fun they felt fantastic
yeah
i love it so when i have to cover my
feet because i think i'll not be allowed
to like new york you don't wear sounds
in new york yeah it's frowned upon i
don't even like you i wouldn't want to
wear
sandals in new york looking at their
streets yeah you get for sure disgusting
you get aids back when you're 22. you
can get it now work whatever age i am at
now yeah we're going to new york is back
to being clean we're on this i'll be
there this weekend it's back to being
clean i think last time you went there
no i was just there really i was i was
there uh no i would say no it's filthy
it's better than it was
all [ __ ] up yeah
it was definitely yeah there's so much
money in times square there's so much
[ __ ] money there's definitely places
that are super nice goddamn grease was
nice [ __ ]
greece is like multiple yeah
great great segue away from new york
into greece
the delta between those two are is
gigantic profound and scenic i just was
rereading parts of your book and i'm in
greece and i felt like that on a yacht
and i felt like the biggest [ __ ] yeah
just a [ __ ] i know are there knife nice
parts of uh afghanistan yes there is
yeah really nice park yep tell them the
story about just can you take us through
what you've been through this fire fight
you've it's been the most horrific thing
yeah you're coming back into the valley
of death you know you're going to be
ambushed again and then you you get he's
getting ambushed again they get ambushed
people die
it's it's the same [ __ ] and and i'll
take it from there it's an amazing
three-day gun fight to get into this fob
we kind of
refit
reload fight our way back out gun fight
again but this time we were a little bit
more aggressive in what our response was
going to be so like when the at when the
ambush was initiated we already had a10
warthogs pre-positioned for gun runs
so as like the ambush starts the ambush
line is defined a10 goes
and just like again vaporizes everything
fight our way out and um
we make it into this village and as
we're driving through this past this
really narrow pass there's this lone
tree i mean right out of sleepy hollow
horror story this old nasty tree and
there's a dead rotting body hanging from
the tree i was like
this could could essentially
summarize my past week right here this
is perfect cool
i'm gonna experience more of the same
horrors that i've experienced for the
past week and i roll into this video or
into this village
and all of these people start coming out
beautiful they look
asian russian
pretty much every invading nation that
has been in this country is genetically
in these people
like green eyes red hair freckled faces
you know almond shaped eyes gorgeous
just stunning looking people
and uh the women
are like looking at me like
looking at me giving a liking no like
humans oh gotcha you know all the other
villages they're totally covered they
wouldn't look at you because like were
they invading
not what was happening but that's how
they treated us
and this old man walks up and hugs me
and it was the first time
that an afghan had had any physical
contact with me that wasn't trying to
murder me
you stabbed him in the neck no i cried i
didn't start crying i cried i started
crying i'm sorry the dead hanging body
came out he touched your hand first
right oh there's a taliban body they
hung a taliban body at the entrance to
the village being like if you come in
here
you're either gonna have to kill all of
us or you're going to have to step over
our dead bodies and piles of brass to
get to the next person behind us because
they had bad guys positioned and all
around us and so i saw this farming town
yeah it was total agriculture they had
as if we went back
a thousand years there's tears a little
town it was gorgeous so shangri la is
like this mythical city in the himalayas
that you know desert doesn't exist and
you don't get old there there's no
there's no violence there's no war um
you know there's no theft there's no
rape there's no murder yeah and and
that's what it felt like going into this
little village and it was just people
wanting to live they wanted to be left
alone and there was there was a
statement of that at the front entrance
we don't support this yeah wow you come
in here i'm gonna hang your your your
corpse from there give you like food
right like pomegranates and [ __ ]
like yeah and you know growing up in in
central california with pomegranates
trees on a property so you like
again the brain that spectrum of you
know having roots in hell and and
finally like feeling and touching
humanity uh you know tasting a
pomegranate and being thrown back to a
childhood and remember the memories of
my dad trying to like mentor and nurture
young men about what it was going to be
like because i'm eating this pomegranate
and this old man is like you know it's
because he could see he's probably he'd
probably seen russia
he'd probably see the british
you know he's obviously seen the taliban
you know he might have been old enough
to know genghis khan yeah and he and
when you started crying in his arms that
he must he just held on to you it's just
just how i i started crying you started
sleeping like i did in austin yeah just
like
it's you know you you bury stuff and
but it's still in there yeah and i don't
know how people access that after war um
you know but this guy just by like one
touch
that did it he just
[ __ ] opened it up i was like we're
all i love humans
some of us were just like what is going
on some guys were still like are we
about to is this about to go down yeah
yeah like why are these people getting
close they got a bomb vest on yeah you
know like
they're gonna wear my skin tonight when
i go to sleep
jesus christ and and and how long were
you in that village it's not long enough
i should have stayed there forever yeah
such a cool [ __ ] chapter like it was
such an unexpected it's almost like you
you stepped into the shire
yeah you know what i mean like yeah bill
baggins comes running out he's like yeah
well what i thought was really cool is
that there is humanity there is great
humanity in hell like you can find the
oasis can find the situation harbor and
the tempest you know yeah like right now
and people are
struggling with everything
abortions happening right now you know
of all these students just have like you
know inflation the 2020 or the 2022
midterm elections and everybody's like
like
first like we're humans
second
we're americans
let's just just take a breath
and and be cool yeah be cool it's that
you're talking like as a guy who touched
so much violence you know that's that's
wisdom you know it's like it makes you
in some ways harder but softer right
yeah people throw around revolution both
sides right now and it's like
they have no idea you people
they've never been punched in the face
never yeah you people you people well
that's what i was saying about when i
heard these kids then they were kind of
on college campuses and saying we need a
violent overthrow of the system and i
was like you kids have never done a
contact sport you have no idea and there
are guys like you out there and if you
you don't awake in that face dude what
oh no they have no idea this is
ignorance it's like people who think
that like the guy asked me how i do in a
fight against you he really did he goes
you're a black belt you wrestle in high
school you're a black belt in taekwondo
you box and they go how would you do
against brennan if you really went out
and i go is that a serious question a
professional heavyweight ufc fighter who
played profile you know but if you don't
if you've never done it you don't
remember that rich guy at the cons film
festival who wanted to get a single leg
on me dude he was super rich and he gets
up on i think his wife a lot of guys
want to hook up i don't know yeah how
about you or you wouldn't quit
alpha male alpha male but small little
guy small the rich guy in the room and
very very wealthy and just decided he
gets up on the table
yeah he gets on the table he goes like
this let's go let's go and brenda's
going you got to just tell him to stop
get him away from me so i'm going to
have to do something that's so important
i'll go different routers like hey rich
guy um you get a single leg
i'll do your wife
if i stuff you you give me that watch
yeah that's right that's good
this is the evil of me this is why
politics is out because like
i don't think it's so dude i still got
those roots i
to do like uh the book launch was the
library of congress and uh
literally just stood up and walked away
from people
otherwise i would have committed
oh because they were were they what is
it like an assault in virginia if i like
just take somebody's face off um
yeah okay not just for so there are two
options you peel their face off if you
just if you scatter them you make a
small incision and just you pull the
face down get assault and everything
like leave the room yeah or face off
were you getting that kind of [ __ ] from
people no they wanted stuff
they were like hey you know if you if
you you got this issue that i want you
to like
talk about they want to be the poster
boy whatever agenda they're trying to
push oh and it will make like a donation
you know i was like
so you'll donate to a group trying to
save people's lives in exchange for me
doing this thing for you wow first of
all you're a horrible human second i'm
gonna take your face yeah and third he
is two comma ten
off the table you guys pissed him off
but donate to brendan
you guys are working i'll push the
agenda i'll talk to i'll take the powers
it be uh do we current events and are we
good it's up to you guys an event
is there anything to talk about with him
i mean you guys already covered like roe
versus wade being overturned right yeah
i also have no input on that yeah yeah i
mean i like people can people just like
be people yeah yeah whatever women want
to do i'm like freedom about everything
see this is like the hypocrisy like all
these people like no no freedom like
right to bear arms you know freedom of
speech you like you know know the
patriot act you'll be like heaven forbid
you make sure other people have freedoms
that you're not comfortable with yeah so
this is where i'm just like a freedom
first about everything i'm not gonna be
hypocrite right like if you wanna smoke
weed awesome like i will fight for your
right to smoke weed like you want to
identify as whatever cool yeah i'm going
to be a hypocrite if i'm going to sit
here and be like i want all my freedoms
but you can't you want to marry somebody
with the same sex i'll fight for that
yeah you're like i'll be with you versus
waiting it's more of a constitutional
thing right so founding father's like no
that's not in there yeah there are two
things just to educate people one is
that that
the the idea was it's been the law for
50 years and what that means is that
usually the supreme court almost always
goes with what's called precedence which
means that it is a it is a it was a law
that was passed that has become in many
ways ingrained in the law of the land
okay so precedence was you hear the word
a lot precedence was it's it's an issue
that in fact is law there's no point in
overturning it 75 of americans you know
support it and every one of the
confirmations of these conservative
justices essentially said that amy comey
barrett and the other two they basically
were like the the law is precedence and
it would be a state-by-state it's not
really my job and it's kind of been
settled yeah of course
what with justice thomas
who is a staunch and strict
constitutionalist so that's the black
guy right yes so so if you look at
scalia and the conservatives there are
two ways to interpret the constitution
one is it is not a living document it is
a fixed document if you if you start
interpreting it and you start you start
making it malleable to your political
position it loses its its strength so
the idea was they said wait a minute roe
v wade
is not in the constitution it is not a
constitutional issue
therefore well therefore it is a state
issue
so the state now it the battleground
becomes the state okay so the state has
to it's really left up to the state
legislature and
as like a small government person i love
that it's a state issue but i also hate
the just like or three dudes talking
about like women's reproductive health
and then what's next you know like it's
because gay marriage isn't in there so
is it well so here's here so so they
just so yes they're going to bring that
up and they're going to bring up
contraception
of course it is it's a slippery slope
but i also don't want federal government
mandate like i live in texas for a
reason as as californians are leaving
fleeing the state yeah for freedom
but yeah you're going but then you know
texas then is like okay well am i a
freedom state first
if i'm going to
limit access to women's reproductive
health care if i'm going to not allow so
like that's that's where it is so
nuances so it's part of the american
experiment and what's going to happen is
you're going to have states that that
you're going to have abortion terrorism
uh tourism if you will uh they're going
to be a lot doesn't sound like a good
idea well they're going to be a lot of
people a lot of corporations are already
are saying we will pay for your leave
and for you to get disney medical help
a lot of people a lot of corporations
are so
talk about they're just thinking about i
know it's going to be a [ __ ]
battlefield show but here's the biggest
problem people that can't afford to
leave the state yes poor people
people of color communities of color
they're the ones they're going to have
that are going to have children
that are they they can't afford children
and i know people are like well it's
their responsibility i get it i'm all
about personal reasons
like everybody in this [ __ ] room yeah
like everybody in this [ __ ] room so
uh my thing is
are you gonna you guys are not gonna
take care of those children those
children are gonna have to find
something you know a home somewhere i i
it's a very
i wish they would just left it
yeah well so do i and then i wish
for people this is a very this is a
religious
issue it's an uncompromising issue for a
lot of people and they believe that the
sanctity of life begins at contraception
that's a huge thing
or the heartbeat as soon as there's a
heartbeat so in six weeks you can you
can you can six weeks you can sense a
heartbeat so it's the heartbeat law so
in texas once you can detect a heartbeat
it would be illegal to get enough no
matter what yes incest everything yes
and that's what's going to happen oh by
the way and rape and cess come on so i
have a huge problem that's a problem
and we're the three bros here aren't
going to figure it out that's why that's
why i've always been protected on the
couch and and we like break it down i'm
pro-choice but here's this you can speak
to this like the the the other supreme
court decision was it is
unconstitutional to say to somebody
you're not allowed to carry
a gun this is a new year
so again if i'm gonna be freedom first i
gotta be freedom first and
there's nobody's gonna be able to tell
me how or when i'm gonna be able to
protect my family do you believe do you
believe that people should take a course
and learn about i think it's the
individual responsibility okay like if
i'm gonna carry a firearm yeah i have to
be trained i have to be competent using
it people won't
people don't yeah but they should be
right because they should be other
things you have to do that for a car
yeah drive a car
uh a bunch of stuff we're gonna get a
lot by the way just just
just saying in this country on this
podcast just saying that people should
probably take a course where i'm going
to get
50 000 emails or whatever like you're
[ __ ] am i saying you have to mandate
it it's a very important i don't know
but what i'm saying is that i'm saying i
don't know for me to carry a gun i want
to be competent in using this gun me too
is it the government's job to tell me
how i can protect my family absolutely
not no like if you're gonna be like hey
you can't carry a gun you can't carry at
this place at this time sorry man but
see this is my family i'm gonna i'm
gonna protect them how i want to because
you guys are gonna do
who are super gun control like fanatics
call time yeah eight minutes eight
minutes
everybody's dead well the cop told me
because i had an issue at my house years
and years ago the cop goes it's about
eight minutes or average time you so we
tell everyone you'll be able to fight
for eight minutes eight minutes fighting
the ufc i go you i looked down you know
how long eight minutes is because yeah
but you would be fine i'm fine try some
majority of people eight minutes dude
fighting for your life they're [ __ ]
yeah everybody's [ __ ] yeah i mean i
i'd take me i'd have to i'd need i
probably couldn't keep you off my back
would take at least seven minutes you
know well i hate they're gonna give up i
hate though i'm gonna get choked out tim
yeah
what else you got sticking my finger in
the cage
are we doing current events yeah
okay look at him tim's body what a dick
[ __ ]
about the trans uh ruling in swimming
are they banned uh the international
governing body uh banned transgender
swimming after the ncaa
i agree with
and uh do you how mad i would be if my
daughter got
scholarship
yeah lost her scholarship got eliminated
from a national competition or going to
the olympics or you're second or last
she loses her all-american status
doesn't make the olympics that's what
happened that girl she was all-american
for three years her senior year she gets
bumped out of it because the transgender
girl fish ahead of her and she's like
this isn't right man like my senior year
i've placed all-american every single
[ __ ] time and now i'm out of it
there's an epic photo
on the podium of the first
no not the swimming one this is i think
it was a triathlon um or it was a uh
yeah it was a triathlon first and second
were true trans athletes the third was
taking a photo and it was um
sis
so a woman that identifies as a woman
that was born a woman
um and she's holding both of her
children and the two
female trans athletes
that transitioned from male to female
and then competed as female as athletes
got first and second
and she's standing there by herself and
you're just like oh it's so annoying to
me uh yeah i don't know
who would think that's a lot of people
because they don't think about it but
they've also never do i want an
inclusive environment where a trans
athlete can feel safe to be able to
compete
yes different yeah different questions
let them compete they're going to make
an open category absolutely
but i want my daughters to compete level
playing field fairly yes
my thing about all of this is that i'm
i'm mandated to think about this and
talk about this in a certain way and
it's 15 minutes old so when you when i'm
not if i say a man's a man and a woman's
woman i get banned from twitter for life
that's the problem you know
you're you're you're enforcing this
ideology and these ideas that that
they're acting like are settled science
which are new
um
on people who are like
wait a minute here this is this is this
is current events is sketchy
it's scary you guys do this on every one
of your podcasts yeah
uh that's just him crying for help
because she's so hot yeah actually yeah
so she didn't kelly i get it yeah
she is you know she's brilliant too uh i
know her and i've worked with her and
she's brilliant brilliant right she's
very smart and she's a reader she's
smart as [ __ ] yeah she read my book and
she's cool you know what i don't know
that's how smart she is i think she's
singled him now that she's with like
megan kelly or something
again
no not megan machine kelly making
kelly's also hot and kind of very pretty
and pretty smart yes she's just
brilliant woman too a smart woman
yeah megan fox just has all she has all
the cards oh
yeah one of the hottest ones
i put the shotgun in my mouth and
yelling on the phone and like the
barrels of my mouth i go to [ __ ] the
shotgun the bullet as it comes back up
the shell just gets jammed look at my
face do we believe this story look at my
face i got a skeptical hip-hop yeah
skeptic doesn't make sense in how a
shotgun operates she might make you kill
yourself i mean there are women out
there that'll break your [ __ ] back
kill you right now i know like we're
we've been friends i'll do six years for
her hard time you would you would choke
me you you kill me you break my neck
yeah kelly you'd be like i'm sorry brian
no
megan fox yes
no yeah yeah you would if we were just
we were here and she was the last woman
on earth and i was like guys take it she
likes me me and tim are killing you she
likes my personality and
then me and tim were doing she was like
you guys should fight it out
[ __ ] yeah we're killing you dude i call
it i carry a small knife dude
what happens i go tim i don't want tim i
don't want anything
sorry you know you know that you know
the guy who's like that he's like oh
tim all that exercise all that training
i'm sorry as i drag it up you're like
and then i can't believe it
[Music]
uh the first of never okay
i would love to uh you know i would love
to learn from you and videotape it it
was like me trying to move around so we
have a helicopter pig hunt on the on the
books we've got to figure out
waterboarding
we're going to talk through that before
before can we do it can we do a can we
do a walk a junior varsity version of it
no there's only one way to do it that's
just tim's gonna do a mock
[ __ ] trial yeah how long can i get a
can i get a time period sleep
deprivation and malnutrition nutrition
are definitely added i don't want that
can you put them in one of those little
uh things like i see on the zero dark 30
where they put force them in like the
coffin oh that's the worst yeah that's
what i want for them so the pain
positions where you like you get in a
box you can't stand all the way up you
know or a box you can't take a full
breath in so they put you in a locker oh
my god and they have different sized
lockers
oh my god so like we wait and we're
trying to shove but i wait for you to
exhale and then i shove you in so you
can't take a full
dude i'm gonna do i'm gonna tell you
what happened i'm singing yeah but it's
also i'm gonna tell you swamped so it's
like hitting the top of your head so
you're kind of you're crying like this
but you also can't breathe oh we're
gonna leave you in there for how long
you're gonna do it how long i'm gonna
have you you can't tell me how i wake up
tomorrow four hours
think about the pain in your knees
you can't breathe and i i like pull on
you oh that'd be nice but then i pushed
you back
i'm telling you what is it [ __ ] i'm
you're sick of this look at him you want
to see what satan looks like
look at you oh look at that look at his
teeth
you are dark so dude i feel like the
room just got dark i can't breathe nuts
i was on a flight for 27 hours last
night i'm [ __ ] i'm already waiting
what's up with that is that a mustache
what's up what me yeah you yeah it's a
little mustache is it
a mustache
he said is it
i'm not talking about me i don't know if
you're talking with me but yeah this is
a mustache okay but a little smell my
brother's korean and we don't let him do
that why because it looks terrible
because i love my brother and i'll be
like your brother's korean yeah
how's he he's adopted
you guys are the smartest
yeah i put that together i did it i was
like what the [ __ ] is happening
yeah i don't yeah
so he was married he was actually
adopted yeah well so
he's actually my brother-in-law okay but
he was my crib mate growing up as a kid
and my sister
they get best friend since we're this
big also basically brothers and then
yeah and then my
sister marries him
and that's pretty cool that's super
super cool hold on hold on
cool um
was she also a crit so that that was
her brother too no like they've known
each other since they're like one
yep
what
fun 15 16 years old when cops show up
and they're like hey caught this dude
climbing out this window and like what
window that window and it's like that's
my sister's window and my brother's like
that's our sister's window
chad what are you
oh oh
oh come come inside chad wow
they've been married like 20 years they
got beautiful
my half
irish
korean so cute
they got green irish eyes they got like
the red strawberry blonde hair but they
have like the perfect almond shaped eyes
they're just like the most every one of
them are the most
gorgeous kids is he military or he's so
he he works for a diablo canyon nuclear
power plant okay
don't try to go there to do bad things
my brother will kill you oh jesus so
yeah everybody in your family is a
[ __ ] killer if i break into that
house
my brother brother um is an fbi bomb
tech detective sergeant
and then uh jesus christ
yeah and then my brother i wonder what a
normal day is like for him i have my
brother
tim tim what i gathered from your book
is that you were not just a green beret
because you started out as a p a x 18 or
something which was they they needed
more special forces guys that's right
and so they recruited a bunch of like
physically gifted guys problem is the
age for green berries dropped by seven
years and get this they were dying at an
exponential rate double double that of
double that average sf guy and the sf
guys were like these [ __ ] muscular
little these meatheads are in here yeah
you're really good but knowing who to
kill well we weren't really good we
weren't really good right we were like
little muscle meatheads without any
experience but now i i gather that you
you
really did
you did things
you're part you were part of elite
squadrons that i didn't know
there's there maybe i didn't even know
they existed that's the point ah you
know so when people think about the
status quo groups yeah let's talk about
them wow
yeah yeah there's i mean there's some
really we i'm so proud of our all vil
volunteer military you know we longest
war in american history all volunteer
going over to fight the longest war in
american history
back to the the construct conscriptions
like the draft of vietnam and
how
damaging it was to american life and
american culture we just fought the
longest war in history everyone that was
there volunteered to be there wanted to
be there i mean that's wild that's cool
and we we also i think have the most
powerful military ever to walk the face
the planet think about that yeah well i
worry a little bit that we have about 10
000 or maybe a thousand whatever it is
we have a secret army that that
nobody really has a name for or knows
about and i worry a little bit about
that not that i'm saying anything i'm
just saying we have to kill him ah [ __ ]
he knows too much he's gone too far
would it be cool though if you came into
a room tim and you had this secret
mission and i was [ __ ] standing there
with my arms behind and i was like
eddie's sergeant or whatever the [ __ ]
you are yeah and then you were like well
brian you're like brian i was like
that's right otherwise known as
white falcon yeah black female [ __ ]
otherwise known black right
i know i'm great falcons [ __ ]
yeah
man cheetah
that's a good name dude
that's the start of a book and i give
you your orders that's your book hey do
we get a percentage of that percent okay
because
like the origin of the story just
created it he's on board okay i wouldn't
like if jk rowling was here and it's
like all right so this guy has this
lightning bolt in his forehead and
there's this bad guy voldemort and he is
like cool
my chapters would be i beat up a french
guy who didn't know how to fight once
that would be my chapter yeah bad b.o
great great chapter yeah
that's racist what else you got give us
one more chin then i get a roll okay
well real quick with the mustache thing
you're not the first one to tell me that
like girls always tell me if if i shave
my mustache i'll look cuter okay so my
mom too
but when i look at myself in the mirror
when i look at myself in pictures i feel
like the mustache looks better
well but if girls are telling you they
don't like it no they don't say that
they don't like it
i look cuter with fair point i think you
have a great head shape you got thank
you you kind of have good high
cheekbones you know you you got good
full lips
[Music]
he's 45 asian he's a handsome yeah my
brother my brother dude he looks like
he's the exact same as i remember him in
high school i was like you are seriously
are you 17 right or you're 44. the only
thing have a little bit when asians turn
like 76 overnight cinderella which i
agree with
i'll take looking like i'm 20 until i'm
70. i'll take that [ __ ] what am i
going to do at 76 anyway my wife hates
me
already okay so the last one me and mark
on the same page so i had this up
earlier i don't know have you heard
about really rudy giuliani saying that
he got attacked by someone yeah after
the roe versus wade thing yeah someone
said he made it up he okay let me play
his
well this is what he says so far you
can't say that you did things when
things don't happen i know like hey i
got assaulted by these two white guys
and they threw a noose around my neck
there's cameras everywhere there's not
an inch unless you go to like
podunk
nowhere texas there's no there's cameras
everywhere yeah well you said you guys
felt a bam and they said it i didn't i i
don't know if they helped me not fall
down but i was just about to fall down
it's tremendous pain in back you know
all this all the stuff yeah redmond he's
swelling substantial pain to the back
and left i don't like that people hit
him he's an older man but look what
happened here this is the same thing
after the video came out this is what
happened to him the guy that's it they
just tapped him on the back but he said
what's up scumbag
so why because of that well that's not a
cool thing to do that's not cool but he
said that that was that wasn't a nice
that was a nice touch
i'll i'll give that to him but it's also
um being a soft society like walking up
and and touching the stranger isn't cool
like you come up and touch me i
shouldn't touch people the softest touch
ever i'm still going to turn around like
a like a
hyena that's been starved to tear your
face off yeah you know um but that was
even more so like that was an aggressive
touch but you're a grown man and a dude
talks smack to you and smacks you on the
back
yeah that's it yeah yeah cool just turn
around be like
i had nothing to do with that dude back
shut up yeah get on my [ __ ] face and
the end of story so he went like his
team released a statement saying like he
had assaulted he released the statement
saying like it was like incredible pain
it was like hardcore
you know the bummers
probably 97 but do you know the bumper
thing about it that's right is rudy
giuliani like now i know the whole trump
stuff everyone makes fun of him he used
to be a real badass [ __ ] super
battery stood up to the mafia yes
the rico act is all
rudy giuliani like real badass how about
the fact that he also turned new york
around remember 911 yes remember 911 he
goes dude can't be afraid we have to
just stand up to these people
he was going to be they thought he was
going to run for president he got
knighted he's the most beloved [ __ ]
person on earth and then obviously now
you're only you know what you are as of
late like what the media portrays you as
he was trump's lawyer you're talking
about a real bad ass back in the day
though he still is yeah i mean i'm not a
fan of trump's i mean i'll say it out
loud i'm not a fan of trump's but i lie
but giuliani you know he's allowed to be
friends with the guy and he knew him
forever you know he may have his fault
because he's so just because i disagree
with him doesn't mean i yeah yeah the
two ends of that spectrum is like don't
walk up and hit an 80 year old man in
the back yeah also if you're a man and
somebody smacks you in the back and
talks smack like don't be a [ __ ] about
it just turn around be like hey
[ __ ] don't touch me yes yeah
that's right yeah don't do a press
release
yeah that's exactly right so do not
[ __ ] touch me tim yeah okay
radical center yeah
is that it chin that's it what is
amazing what about jesse smells millet
that's old
no so he was on he was on sway show you
know sway in the morning whatever i love
sway and he's also uh he was at the bet
awards and just acting really cool and
people were just kidding you already
made fun of him right
yeah yeah he was i didn't even know that
he was back in the news i was just
he went to on an interview with sway
which is a big pretty much big interview
huge then he kept saying how like
is this before he goes back he's just
been doubling
down okay he can't go anywhere but that
he was in prison for like a few days
that was it he's supposed to be there
for one day yeah they got like
prison tattoos and [ __ ] yeah but he said
him lying about this is like him putting
a fist into black people's culture for
400 after 400 years
he's just a douchebag he sucks
but we're talking about him again you
know you're right exactly what he wanted
we're making fun of
thank you for what you do dude yeah
thank you thank you for you guys i'm
really proud of you and we're people if
they want to get the book it's sold out
basically everywhere dude in person it
is hard they're trying to do reprinting
so if you see it on the shelf somewhere
snag it
it's the best name for a book i mean
scars and stripes come on
yeah so the stripes in the military you
earn the same way that we earn
scars like it's literally time overseas
you get combat stripes and then your
your stripes on your other sleeve are
the stripes of your ti your years in
service wow and then your stripes for
your rank is like you earn so you
literally just like i don't know
anything else no that's so i love you
guys man i love you man freedom first
keep just getting out there first
amendment is so important yeah when we
lose that and you guys always push the
envelope both as comedians and as like
podcasters like this is the new front
lines for freedom when it comes to like
discourse dude yeah you have to be able
to talk satire discourse you know
[ __ ] changing your mind you got to do
it yeah you got to do it and if you love
freedom i'll be in fort wayne indiana
july 14th or 16th san diego is july 21st
through 23rd i end in baltimore on the
trash panda summer tour baltimore's
august 4th through the 6th and appleton
wisconsin september 8th through the 10th
take it tickets houston boston you got
it buddy okay let's do it but uh fort
wayne indiana you're up next july 14th
through 16th come see me brookfield
wisconsin milwaukee improv july 21 23 i
am an awesome captain
28th 29th 30th anything you want anybody
you want i got tickets for you all right
austin cap city they just opened by the
way they just opened i'm excited yeah
then nashville tennessee zany's august
25 26 27 great i know this is these are
great cities [ __ ] yeah then i got
spokane washington which i actually love
september 22nd 23rd
and best of my uh youtube show ron we're
about to drop episode four check it out
it's going to be exciting so since you
have water boarded by tim kennedy
we got that we got i'm ready dude all
right i'm i'm gonna hold it board games
war games with andy stump and mike
glover [ __ ] him up and then
that way hog hunting get water boarded
by tim kennedy when are you back from
wherever you're going i don't know we're
on this closed location
until the mission is done
you make it sound sexy it's not it's
like it is i have to go work until the
work is done you know i just asked me
when he's gonna be when's he gonna be
back we'll see a little bit tim this is
tim this is how i want you to always
answer everything watch this uh when
somebody says so this i'll be tim
kennedy
ask me yeah and say say uh what are you
doing what are you doing in ukraine
right now what are you doing ukraine tim
you just keep waking up free every
morning and i'll do what i do buddy
how's that sound yeah i like that too
see that dude and then when you're
coming back then when
you want to grab dinner or something
when you're coming back
when i'm done taking care of business
yeah see that sounds so bad i see that
dude i don't know my voice yeah i heard
it i heard it that's a good time to
figure tim thank you brother i love you
go get his book